Favourite food, go. Spaghetti and meatballs. Spaghetti and meatballs, that's pretty good. What about fusilli? What about food? What about fusilli and meatballs? No, that falls under the same... That's the same category.
最喜欢的食物，说。意大利面配肉丸。意大利面配肉丸，那还不错。螺旋粉怎么样？食物怎么样？螺旋粉配肉丸怎么样？不，那属于同一类……那是同一类。
It's just pasta. No, I'm talking about, okay, so... I like Pat for belly. No, no, no. Let's not get into different kinds of pasta. Pasta, yeah. No, pasta. Remember when Jason...
那只是意大利面。不，我是说，好吧，所以……我喜欢帕特（Pat）的肚子。不，不，不。我们别去讨论不同种类的意大利面了。意大利面，对。不，意大利面。还记得杰森（Jason）……
I like French fries. If I could have one single thing, it would be French fries. One single thing. One single thing for me would be ice cream. Okay, great. Welcome to SmartLens. Smart.
我喜欢炸薯条。如果我只能吃一样东西，那一定是炸薯条。一样东西。对我来说，一样东西就是冰淇淋。好的，太棒了。欢迎来到SmartLens。Smart。
Lens. Smart. Lens. Smart. Lens. Hey, Will, is that a... Let's go. Spider-Man...
Lens。Smart。Lens。Smart。Lens。嘿，威尔（Will），那是……我们开始吧。蜘蛛侠……
Yeah, he's got a Spider-Man chair. He's sitting in a Spider-Man chair. It's Abel's chair because I'm in my new booth and it's not finished yet and so on. I love how you blame it on the kids. I'm not blaming it on. I'm explaining what it is. That's your new booth and your new house?
对，他有一把蜘蛛侠椅子。他正坐在蜘蛛侠椅子上。那是阿贝尔（Abel）的椅子，因为我在我的新录音棚里，还没装修好，诸如此类。我喜欢你把责任推给孩子。我不是在推卸责任。我是在解释这是怎么回事。那是你的新录音棚和新房子？
Yeah. It's not finished. I gotta put the carpet's not in yet and... Are you gonna put leather floors in this one too? You fucking douchebag. No, don't be an idiot. We're going suede. You know, I'm not happy with my podcast room set up here.
对。还没装修好。我得把地毯还没铺好，还有……你打算在这间房也铺皮革地板吗？你这个混蛋。不，别犯傻了。我们要用麂皮。你知道，我对现在的播客室布置不太满意。
The couch I'm sitting on... None of us is. It's not comfortable. And I feel like... Can I ask you, is your couch from an old house? Is this just like a leftover? It looks like you're in a room that's full of leftovers. Like from your college days.
我坐的这张沙发……我们谁都不满意。它不舒服。我觉得……我能问问吗，你的沙发是从旧房子搬来的吗？这只是剩下的东西吗？看起来你住在一个全是旧货的房间里。就像你大学时代留下的。
It is. And I'm looking at a Pilates bench, whatever you call it in front of me. Reformer. Reformer. Yeah, I just feel like it's time to admit that we're gonna be doing this for a while and I ought to untemporary my situation.
确实是。我正看着一个普拉提长凳，不管你把它叫什么，就在我面前。核心床（Reformer）。核心床。对，我只是觉得是时候承认我们要长期做这个了，我应该让我的环境不再那么临时。
Well, make yourself comfortable. Why wouldn't you make yourself... Get something, a scenario that you're happy to go sit in. Well, also sitting up straight, Jay. Like my posture. I don't want you to hurt your lower back. Well, that's my point. It's impossible to sit up straight in this couch.
好吧，让自己舒服点。你为什么不让自己……找个场景，让你坐着开心。好吧，还有坐直，杰伊（Jay）。就像我的姿势。我不想让你伤到下背部。好吧，这就是我的观点。在这张沙发上根本不可能坐直。
And I mean... I mean, should I dress for it too? I'm still on my pajamas. The dressing is fine. I think it's more... It's the posture I think it's... And I think it's making you... It's affecting your mood.
而且我是说……我是说，我也该为此打扮一下吗？我还穿着睡衣呢。打扮没问题。我觉得更多的是……是姿势，我觉得是……而且我觉得它让你……它影响了你的心情。
Quite frankly. You think I have a shitty attitude. Yeah, it's making you shitty attitude because all your organs are crunched up. You have to elongate those organs. Hey, man, let's keep it classy. So let's get on the reformer. And I'm gonna come over there.
坦白说。你觉得我态度很烂。对，这让你态度很烂，因为你所有的器官都挤在一起了。你得把那些器官拉伸开。嘿，伙计，保持优雅。所以我们去用核心床吧。我会过去那边的。
I can be there in about four minutes. And I'm gonna come over and I'm gonna lengthen your organ. With an S or a Z. Or a Z. Okay, so our guests today. Are you guys ready for one of my great written intros again? They're so funny, guys. Now, what happens when you write...
我大概四分钟就能到。我会过去，然后我会拉伸你的器官。用S还是Z？或者Z。好的，那么我们今天的嘉宾。你们准备好听我再次写的那段精彩开场白了吗？伙计们，它们太搞笑了。现在，当你写的时候会发生什么……
Do you write this thing? How many gummies in there when you write this? Well, I don't think I've swallowed them yet, but I'm still sort of picking them out of my teeth. Put them in the back of your throat. So this is the ninth draft. Okay, this is how good this intro is. Wow.
你写这个东西吗？你写这个的时候吃了多少软糖？嗯，我觉得我还没咽下去，但我还在从牙缝里抠它们。把它们放在喉咙后面。所以这是第九稿。好的，这就是这段开场白有多好。哇。
Actually, it's only about six minutes old. Our guest today is one of the most popular figures in music, comma, worldwide, period. He started at the young age of 17 in the band we all know and love. Steve Winwood. Called Scream. He's now in his third band.
其实它才写了六分钟。我们今天的嘉宾是音乐界最受欢迎的人物之一，逗号，全世界，句号。他17岁时就在我们大家都知道并喜爱的乐队开始了。史蒂夫·温伍德（Steve Winwood）。叫Scream。他现在在第三个乐队。
He's been inducted into the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame and is about to be inducted for the second time. Wait, what? He's directed numerous videos and a few documentaries. He's been on SNL, Saturday Night Live, Tracy, 14 times. Wow. He has long dark hair, great smile, and loves animals, long hikes, and short stories.
他入选了摇滚名人堂，并且即将第二次入选。等等，什么？他导演了无数视频和几部纪录片。他上过SNL，周六夜现场，特雷西（Tracy），14次。哇。他留着长长的黑发，笑容灿烂，喜欢动物、长途徒步和短篇小说。
He's a Capricorn, and don't I know it? Because this fella has the exact same birthday and year as yours truly, friends. This is Dave Grohl. Dave. Oh, Dave Grohl. Hey, Dave. Come on in.
他是摩羯座，我难道不知道吗？因为这家伙的生日和年份跟我本人一模一样，朋友们。这就是戴夫·格罗尔（Dave Grohl）。戴夫。哦，戴夫·格罗尔。嘿，戴夫。进来吧。
Hey, Dave. Oh. Dave Grohl. Look at that Led Zeppelin book. I know. They asked for a towel to cover the camera thing. And you dry yourself off with the Led Zeppelin box set? Exactly.
嘿，戴夫。哦。戴夫·格罗尔。看那本齐柏林飞艇（Led Zeppelin）的书。我知道。他们要了一条毛巾来盖住摄像机。你用齐柏林飞艇的套装擦干自己？正是如此。
Yeah. Hi, guys. Hi. Hey, Dave. Can that take us right to drumming and my personal favorite, John Bonham? Is he number one for you? Absolutely.
对。嗨，伙计们。嗨。嘿，戴夫。那能直接带我们进入打鼓和我个人最喜欢的约翰·博纳姆（John Bonham）吗？他是你心中的第一名吗？绝对是。
No question. Truly. Number one. No question. No question. No one close. OK. When I say the words Neil Pert to you, what does that do to you?
毫无疑问。真的。第一名。毫无疑问。毫无疑问。没人能接近。好的。当我跟你说尼尔·佩尔特（Neil Peart）这个名字时，你有什么感觉？
Well, he's Canadian, so it doesn't really count. He was in Rush, right? Yeah. He was the guy from Rush. Don't say he was the guy from Rush. You're being coy. He was the guy from Rush, by the way. Dave, you're being coy.
嗯，他是加拿大人，所以不算数。他在Rush乐队，对吧？对。他是Rush乐队的那个人。别说他是Rush乐队的那个人。你在装傻。顺便说一句，他就是Rush乐队的那个人。戴夫，你在装傻。
Pretty tight second. A drummer like John Bonham, you have to understand that the thing that defines a drummer is their feel, their signature sound. It's like their fingerprint, right? Every drummer has a different feel. If you have a piece of music and you give it to three different drummers, they'll play it three different ways. Personally, I think that John Bonham was the greatest drummer,
相当紧凑的第二名。像约翰·博纳姆这样的鼓手，你必须明白定义鼓手的是他们的感觉，他们的标志性声音。就像他们的指纹，对吧？每个鼓手都有不同的感觉。如果你有一段音乐，把它给三个不同的鼓手，他们会用三种不同的方式演奏。我个人认为约翰·博纳姆是最伟大的鼓手，
not because of his technical proficiency, which was beyond anyone else. Sure. Not because of his big fat feel, which was better than anyone else, but because he was kind of like, he like teetered on the brink of chaos the entire time. So he could like lay down a big fat groove. Cashmere, good example. Yeah, sure.
不是因为他的技术精湛，那超越了其他人。当然。不是因为他那肥厚的感觉，那比任何人都好，而是因为他就像，他一直徘徊在混乱的边缘。所以他能打出一种肥厚的律动。卡什米尔（Cashmere），很好的例子。对，当然。
The simplicity. But I mean, listen. Frankly, when it comes to warmth, nothing beats Cashmere. But I'm sorry, Dave, I've cut you off. You were about to say that John Bonham had a heavy stick, right? He had a heavy foot. Yes, he was amazing. But here's the thing, when I was young, I got that 2112 record
那种简洁。但我是说，听着。坦白说，说到温暖，没有什么比《卡什米尔》更好的了。但抱歉，戴夫，我打断你了。你刚才要说约翰·博纳姆用的是重鼓棒，对吧？他有一只沉重的脚。是的，他太棒了。但问题是，我年轻的时候，我得到了那张《2112》唱片，
when I was like about seven or eight years old, right? And I was embarrassed to show it to my friends because of Alex Lifeson's camel toe that he had in that particular kimono on the back. And I studied that record and I thought it was amazing. But it's when you listen to Rush, you kind of listen to how he's playing stuff. But with John Bonham, you're listening because you want to know why he's playing. I was going to joke and say why, but you actually said why.
我大概七八岁的时候，对吧？我不好意思把它拿给朋友看，因为亚历克斯·莱夫森（Alex Lifeson）在封底那件特定的和服里露出的骆驼趾。我研究了那张唱片，我觉得它太棒了。但当你听Rush的时候，你是在听他怎么演奏东西。但对于约翰·博纳姆，你听是因为你想知道他为什么那样演奏。我本来想开个玩笑说为什么，但你确实说了为什么。
It's interesting. A little side note, the boys know I just got back from Canada and on my way back yesterday, I stopped in at Harvey's for a burger. It's a great Canadian chain. Oh, right on. Oh, yeah. So I was in there, I was in there. I went in and I had to use the washroom.
很有趣。一个小插曲，伙计们知道我刚从加拿大回来，昨天回来的路上，我在Harvey's停下来吃汉堡。那是一个很棒的加拿大连锁店。哦，太好了。哦，对。所以我当时在那儿，我进去了，我得用洗手间。
Is it over here, the washroom? And as I'm in there taking a squirt all I hear is just very, very, very faintly. I just hear the backsmith and the artist must be the ones. And I'm like this. This is like the national anthem up there. I know. And I will tell you this. The first time when I was first dating my ex-wife, we went up to meet my folks.
洗手间在这边吗？当我进去撒尿时，我听到的只是非常、非常、非常微弱的声音。我只听到铁匠和艺术家一定是那些人。我就像这样。这就像那里的国歌。我知道。而且我会告诉你这个。我第一次和前妻约会时，我们去见我的父母。
The first morning we were in Toronto, we go to a Starbucks and we're waiting in line. Not at Tim Hortons? Not at Tim Hortons. It was a Starbucks. And in front of us was Getty Lee right in front of us. And I turned to Amy and I go every day. Every day up here is just Getty Lee everywhere. Is that right?
我们在多伦多的第一个早晨，我们去星巴克排队。不是蒂姆霍顿（Tim Hortons）？不是蒂姆霍顿。是星巴克。在我们前面的是盖迪·李（Geddy Lee），就在我们前面。我转向艾米（Amy）说，每天。在这里每天到处都是盖迪·李。是这样吗？
Yeah. Anyway. So now to close the John Bonham thing. Jason Bonham, tight second, a bronze, is he in the top five? He's, yes? Well, I do believe in the miracle of DNA. Yes. And that he inherited a lot of his father's skills.
对。总之。所以现在结束约翰·博纳姆的话题。杰森·博纳姆（Jason Bonham），紧随其后的第二名，青铜，他在前五名吗？他是，是的？嗯，我确实相信DNA的奇迹。是的。而且他继承了他父亲的很多技能。
Like when you listen, we were at a studio not too long ago, a couple of years ago. And he was down the hall recording. Yeah. And with the door closed, listening to Jason Bonham play, it sounded like a guy from Led Zeppelin play in. So you're saying the best way to hear Jason Bonham is to hear him through a closed door. I mean, that's not a resounding. He didn't say that.
就像你听的时候，我们不久前在录音室，几年前。他在走廊尽头录音。对。门关着，听杰森·博纳姆演奏，听起来就像齐柏林飞艇的人在演奏。所以你是说听杰森·博纳姆最好的方式是隔着一扇关着的门听。我是说，那不是一个响亮的评价。他没那么说。
Not exactly what I said. No, I know. I know. He does, when he plays with a group that plays Zeppelin, he plays exactly like John did. It sounds just like his dad. He doesn't improvise. It sounds just like his dad. This is all great for these other drummers, but I want to get to you, Dave Grohl, because
不完全是我说的。不，我知道。我知道。他确实，当他和演奏齐柏林飞艇音乐的乐队一起演奏时，他演奏得和约翰一模一样。听起来就像他爸爸。他不即兴发挥。听起来就像他爸爸。这对其他鼓手来说都很好，但我想要了解你，戴夫·格罗尔，因为
look, I have to say, you're a guitarist now and you're a lead singer and you're a frontman. But you decided to give the drums to Taylor. He gave the drums to Taylor. He wanted to let the baby have it. But I will say, I mean, Jesus Christ, it's pretty rad. Can we just take a second? Because you don't probably think about this enough. You're Dave Grohl, drummer from Nirvana.
看，我必须说，你现在是吉他手，也是主唱和主唱。但你决定把鼓交给泰勒（Taylor）。他把鼓交给了泰勒。他想让孩子拥有它。但我得说，天哪，这太酷了。我们能花点时间吗？因为你可能没怎么想过这个问题。你是戴夫·格罗尔，涅槃乐队（Nirvana）的鼓手。
Yeah, that's crazy. And I want to get into everything you've done since. But I want to just say that you're Dave Grohl from Nirvana. Think about that for a second. And I want you to enjoy that because that's pretty fucking rad. I bet he's never thought about it before. No, I don't think he has. But when I was in college, you get this every day of your life.
对，那太疯狂了。我想深入了解你之后所做的一切。但我只想说你是涅槃乐队的戴夫·格罗尔。想一想。我希望你享受这一点，因为这太他妈酷了。我敢打赌他以前从没想过。不，我不认为他想过。但我在大学时，你每天都会遇到这种情况。
I've never met you. It's such an honor to meet you. I think you're amazing. And when I was in college, Nirvana was gigantic. And you know this, that when music has a special and penetrates your soul in a certain way that other things don't. So a lot of people have a relationship with music that brings them back to when they were in a certain point in their life.
我从没见过你。见到你真是我的荣幸。我觉得你太棒了。我在大学时，涅槃乐队非常巨大。你知道，当音乐有一种特殊性并以某种方式渗透到你的灵魂中，而其他东西却不能时。所以很多人与音乐有一种关系，把他们带回到他们生命中某个特定时刻。
And there's not a lot of things that do that. So for me, Nirvana was just massive, right? Thanks. It's just massive. Sorry. But I want to know because everybody knows you're such a phenomenal drummer and guitars. Is there an instrument that you've always wanted to play that
没有多少东西能做到这一点。所以对我来说，涅槃乐队就是巨大的，对吧？谢谢。就是巨大的。抱歉。但我很想知道，因为大家都知道你是一位了不起的鼓手和吉他手。有没有一种乐器是你一直想玩但
you've never picked up or learned yet? My first instrument was a trombone. And I realized that that wasn't cool. Trombone. And then I really started with guitar. That was my first instrument. But the one thing I've always wanted to do, which I promised myself I would learn someday, is tap dance.
你还没拿起或学会的？我的第一种乐器是长号。我意识到那不酷。长号。然后我真正开始用吉他。那是我的第一种乐器。但我一直想做的一件事，我答应自己有一天会学，就是踢踏舞。
Are you serious? I'm dead serious. Come over, I'll teach you in two seconds. Oh my God, I have the shoes, but I've just never done it. I have many pairs. I'm scared to wear them in public. I have the shoes. And one of these, I figured that I could implement a lot of
你是认真的吗？我非常认真。过来，我两秒钟就能教你。天哪，我有鞋子，但我从来没做过。我有好几双。我不敢在公共场合穿它们。我有鞋子。而且其中之一，我想我可以实现很多
my drumming skills and my understanding of rhythm into this. I can't dance, but I think I could do it with my feet, like speed, metal, double kick drum, drumming. I'm going to need both of you to sign a release real quick. And I'm coming over too, because I'm going to video the whole thing if that would be okay. Yeah. No tapes.
我的打鼓技巧和对节奏的理解融入其中。我不会跳舞，但我觉得我可以用脚做到，就像速度金属、双踩鼓、打鼓。我需要你们俩签一份免责声明。我也要过去，因为如果可以的话，我要把整个过程录下来。对。没有磁带。
And we'll both have white claws in our hands. We'll be tap dancing with white claws. Why not? Okay. So Dave, so you knew how to play the drums. You started with the guitar. But then when you did that first album for Foo Fighters, all by yourself, guys, he played every single instrument.
我们手里都会拿着白爪（White Claw）。我们会拿着白爪跳踢踏舞。为什么不呢？好的。所以戴夫，你知道怎么打鼓。你从吉他开始。但当你为喷火战机乐队（Foo Fighters）做那张第一张专辑时，全是你自己，伙计们，他演奏了每一件乐器。
That I did not know. All by himself. Is that true, Dave? That whole first album is nothing but him. And it's stunning. So did that come as a result of you just kind of, you know, screwing around? Or did you go, I'm going to make an album.
这一点我不知道。全是他自己。那是真的吗，戴夫？整张第一张专辑除了他什么都没有。这太令人震惊了。所以那是你只是，你知道，瞎搞的结果吗？还是你决定，我要做一张专辑。
I'm going to have a band. I'm going to be the only musician and I'm going to sing. And here we go. Or was it more just sort of like a, well, let's see if I can kind of do this by myself. And if it kind of gets traction, so be it. Well, when I was young, I figured out how to multi-track with two cassette players, like when I was like 10 or 11 years old,
我要组个乐队。我要成为唯一的音乐家，我要唱歌。我们开始吧。还是更像是一种，好吧，让我们看看我能不能自己做这个。如果它有点起色，那就这样吧。嗯，我年轻的时候，我弄清楚了如何用两台卡带机进行多轨录音，大概在我10或11岁的时候，
where you can take one like Radio Shack cassette player, record guitar onto that, take that cassette and put it into the home stereo, hit play, and then put another cassette in the cassette and play drums along to the guitar. And then you'd have drums and guitar on one cassette. So I was writing songs about like fantastic quality. I just had a crazy experience when you said, when I was young, it reminds me of that lyric in your new song where you're like,
你可以拿一台Radio Shack卡带机，把吉他录进去，把那盘卡带放进家庭音响，按播放，然后把另一盘卡带放进卡带机，跟着吉他打鼓。然后你就会在一盘卡带上有鼓和吉他。所以我写的歌质量非常棒。当你提到“当我年轻的时候”时，我有一种疯狂的经历，这让我想起了你新歌里的那句歌词，你说
when I was a young boy, when I used to have a toy gun. What is that song? It's called Waiting on a War. Waiting on a War, which I've listened to a lot. Cause I listened to a lot of UK radio, you guys. Oh. Cause yeah, cause I'm kind of cool. And my buddy, Johnny Vaughn, plays it a lot on his radio
当我还是个小男孩，当我曾经有一个玩具枪。那是什么歌？它叫《等待战争》（Waiting on a War）。《等待战争》，我听了很多。因为我听了很多英国广播，伙计们。哦。因为对，因为我挺酷的。我的哥们，约翰尼·沃恩（Johnny Vaughn），经常在他们的广播里播放它
station over there. He's a great guy, very hilarious guy. Much funnier than these two, Dave. And he plays it a lot and I love that song. It's such a, yeah. Have you guys heard it? No, they haven't. But it's such a great song.
电台。他是个很棒的人，非常搞笑的人。戴夫，比这两个人有趣多了。他经常播放它，我喜欢那首歌。它太，是的。你们听过吗？不，他们没听过。但这真是一首好歌。
I'm sure they have. It's such a great song. Dave, can I ask you a question? Hang on. Host of the Year has a question. Go ahead. Here we go. Everybody's favorite host.
我相信他们听过。这真是一首好歌。戴夫，我能问你一个问题吗？等等。年度最佳主持人有个问题。请讲。我们来了。大家最喜欢的主持人。
Go ahead. Wait, what's going on? Sean's everybody's favorite. It's so stupid. We just got, we just got some eye heart. He definitely talks the least. Dave, Dave, we just got some eye heart. How do you do it, Sean?
请讲。等等，怎么了？肖恩（Sean）是大家最喜欢的。这太蠢了。我们刚得到了一些iHeart。他绝对说得最少。戴夫，戴夫，我们刚得到了一些iHeart。你是怎么做到的，肖恩？
Hold on. I'm talking to Sean. Sean, Sean, you and I, come on. I wait, I wait for a sliver of an opening and I jump in there. I'm sorry. No. How do you like your omelettes? I don't know.
等等。我在跟肖恩说话。肖恩，肖恩，你和我，来吧。我等，我等一个开口的机会，然后我就跳进去了。抱歉。不。你喜欢什么样的煎蛋卷？我不知道。
Yeah, there it is. Go ahead, Sean. Because I've never met you. I'm truly a big fan. I have to ask you and I apologize because you probably get this a lot. But when you were in Nirvana, I know, hold for it. He loves talking about Nirvana. I just loved them.
对，就是这样。请讲，肖恩。因为我从没见过你。我真的是你的大粉丝。我必须问你，我道歉，因为你可能经常听到这个。但当你在涅槃乐队时，我知道，等等。他喜欢谈论涅槃乐队。我只是太爱他们了。
I loved you and I loved them so much. When you were in it and you were first like meeting and creating music and recording together, did you all know you had something special where there was their in fighting? You're like, this is never going to fucking work out. Like, what were the dynamics? Well, I joined, I met them through a mutual friend. We was in a band called Scream and we came out on, we toured in a van and we toured America, played little clubs and blah, blah, blah.
我爱你，我太爱他们了。当你在里面，你们第一次见面、创作音乐并一起录音时，你们都知道你们有什么特别的东西吗，还是有内斗？你觉得，这永远不会成功。动态是怎样的？嗯，我加入，我通过一个共同的朋友认识了他们。我们在一个叫Scream的乐队，我们开着一辆面包车巡演，我们巡演了美国，在小俱乐部演奏，等等等等。
And we wound up on the West Coast. Our bass player Skeeter decided to just go home without telling anyone. And we were stuck here. That sounds odd for a guy like Skeeter to just disappear. I know, imagine. And it wasn't the first fucking time he'd done it, by the way. He did it in Europe anyway. You think he got his name?
我们最终到了西海岸。我们的贝斯手斯基特（Skeeter）决定不告诉任何人就回家了。我们被困在这里了。对于像斯基特这样的人来说，不告而别听起来很奇怪。我知道，想象一下。顺便说一句，这已经不是他第一次这么做了。他在欧洲也这么干过。你觉得他怎么得名的？
Yeah. So we were stuck in a house in Laurel Canyon full of mud wrestlers who worked at the Hollywood Tropicana. Where in Laurel Canyon was it? It's right next to that house where Ruben records stuff that like mansion. Yes. I know exactly what it is. It's directly next door to that.
对。所以我们被困在劳雷尔峡谷（Laurel Canyon）的一所房子里，里面全是为好莱坞热带那家（Hollywood Tropicana）工作的泥浆摔跤手。在劳雷尔峡谷的哪里？就在鲁本（Ruben）录音的那栋豪宅旁边。是的。我知道那是哪里。就在隔壁。
And so our guitar player and singer were brothers and their sister worked at the Hollywood Tropicana. So we had a place to crash. Anyway, so the Skeeter goes home and then this friend of mine says, hey, you know, Nirvana is looking for a drummer. And I'd heard their first record and I loved it. I thought it was great. And he gave me their number and I called them up and they said, actually, we already have
所以我们的吉他手和歌手是兄弟，他们的妹妹在好莱坞热带那家工作。所以我们有地方住。总之，斯基特回家了，然后我的一个朋友说，嘿，你知道，涅槃乐队在找鼓手。我听过他们的第一张唱片，我很喜欢。我觉得它很棒。他给了我他们的号码，我打电话给他们，他们说，其实我们已经有
a drummer. I was like, cool, okay. Well, if you come down to LA, I'm just living in a house full of mud wrestlers. And so then they called back that night and said, maybe you should call Kurt. And then I got on the phone with Kurt, we started talking and he said, all right, well, if you can come up to Seattle, let's jam. And so I flew up there and yeah, within like two minutes of us playing together, it sounded great.
一个鼓手了。我说，酷，好吧。好吧，如果你来洛杉矶，我只是住在一间全是泥浆摔跤手的房子里。然后他们那天晚上回电说，也许你应该给库尔特（Kurt）打电话。然后我和库尔特通了电话，我们开始交谈，他说，好吧，如果你能来西雅图，我们一起即兴演奏吧。所以我飞了过去，是的，在我们一起演奏两分钟内，听起来就很棒。
Really good. No, no, no. Go ahead. Well, just to that, like kind of like to Sean's thing, like when you're in that gym recording the video that everybody's seen a million times and you're going nuts. It smells like Teen Spirit. Yeah. I don't even need to say it.
真的很好。不，不，不。请讲。嗯，只是针对那个，就像肖恩说的那样，当你在那间健身房录制那个每个人都看过一百万遍的视频，而你快疯了的时候。《少年心气》（Smells Like Teen Spirit）。对。我甚至不需要说出来。
It smells like Teen Spirit. One of the most iconic songs. Did you know in that moment, you're like, we're doing some pretty fucking rad and different here. No, we were like, this is the most spinal tap moment of our entire career. Are you serious? Yeah. I mean, because it was like, there was like fire machines.
《少年心气》。最标志性的歌曲之一。在那一刻你知道吗，你觉得，我们在这里做一些非常酷且不同的事情。不，我们当时想，这是我们整个职业生涯中最像《摇滚万万岁》（Spinal Tap）的时刻。你是认真的吗？对。我是说，因为就像，有火机。
And I directed with a bullhorn like, more fire, more fire. It was like, it was kind of a little weird. When they said, okay, you should call Kurt, was that because you needed to just kind of do like a personality test with him or did you guys talk drum theory? Was it like an audition type of phone call? Well, they had seen our band scream play and I was the guy with the big drums that would beat the shit out of the drums. And they basically said, like, well, if we could get a guy like that, I'm like a disco
我用扩音器指挥说，更多火，更多火。这有点奇怪。当他们说，好吧，你应该给库尔特打电话时，那是因为你需要和他进行某种性格测试，还是你们谈论了鼓理论？那是一个试镜类型的电话吗？嗯，他们看过我们的乐队Scream演奏，我是那个带着大鼓、会把鼓打得稀巴烂的家伙。他们基本上说，好吧，如果我们能找到像那样的家伙，我像个迪斯科
drummer. It was very ACDC full on just like, that's what they needed. And so, and then I just happened to be available. And so when we went up and started playing, also I sang backup vocals, which Kurt was putting on some songs. And so I could sing that too. Was there any joy from Kurt? Like, because every interview, every story, everything I've ever seen is just very heavy
鼓手。那非常ACDC，完全就是，那就是他们需要的。所以，然后我刚好有空。所以当我们上去开始演奏时，我也唱了和声，库尔特在一些歌里也加了和声。所以我也能唱那个。库尔特有任何快乐吗？因为每一个采访，每一个故事，我见过的每一件事都非常沉重
and dramatic. No, this is a popular misconception about Nirvana that it was a total drag. And it wasn't. Yeah, you seemed pretty funny. Kurt was really funny. It had a really fucked up sense of humor. That was great. It was really, really funny.
和戏剧性。不，这是一个关于涅槃乐队的普遍误解，认为那是一场彻底的灾难。事实并非如此。对，你看起来挺有趣的。库尔特真的很有趣。他有一种非常糟糕的幽默感。那太棒了。真的非常非常有趣。
And Novoselic too, the bass player. I mean, we were like the Adams family. Novoselic is six, seven and a half. Right, right. The unplugged MTV, you could tell you guys had a great sort of fun kind of chemistry. You could tell things were pretty dry and rye. Always. Yeah.
还有诺沃塞利奇（Novoselic），贝斯手。我是说，我们就像亚当斯一家（Adams family）。诺沃塞利奇有六英尺七英寸半。对，对。MTV不插电演唱会，你可以看出你们有一种很棒的化学反应。你可以看出事情相当干练和讽刺。总是。对。
But I mean, but then there were times that were really difficult because we basically went from sleeping in a squalid little apartment, eating corn dogs every day to becoming this thing that people now know as Nirvana in the course of like four weeks or six weeks. Right. We were kids. We were like 22, 23 years old. Right. So it was really, there were times that got really difficult.
但我是说，但也有一些非常困难的时刻，因为我们基本上从睡在肮脏的小公寓里，每天吃玉米热狗，到在四到六周的时间里变成了人们现在所知的涅槃乐队。对。我们还是孩子。我们大概22、23岁。对。所以确实，有些时候变得非常困难。
Was that like the middle of 91 when that just first exploded with that? So it was September of 91. Yeah. So that was the first thing that you bought that you felt like, you know what? This is really irresponsible of me. The first thing I did, the first check I got was 400 bucks. It was the most money I'd ever had in my entire life. From Nirvana stuff?
那是91年中期，它刚爆发的时候吗？所以是91年9月。对。所以那是你买的第一件让你觉得，你知道吗？这对我来说太不负责任了。我做的第一件事，我收到的第一张支票是400美元。那是我一生中拥有的最多的钱。来自涅槃乐队的东西？
Yeah, 400 bucks. I was like, fuck. And I went to the Fred Meyer, like Kmart store. I bought a BB gun, a Nintendo, and I got a fucking tattoo. And then I was back to the corn dogs. Like I had nothing. So I fully MC hammered it within like 24 hours, just fucking dropped the whole thing back to the couch in the corn dogs.
对，400美元。我当时想，该死。我去了Fred Meyer，就像Kmart商店。我买了一把BB枪，一台任天堂，我还纹了一个该死的纹身。然后我又回到了玉米热狗的生活。我什么都没有。所以我完全在24小时内像MC Hammer一样挥霍了，只是把整个东西扔回沙发和玉米热狗里。
It's good to learn that lesson on the 400 bucks. So when the big check comes, you go like, all right, I'm not going to do the BB gun again. This is one of the beautiful things about some rock stars. Like you think about someone like Steven Tyler. Oh my God, that guy's had $10 million and then $10 million and then $10 million and then $10 million. And I don't know if he's buying BB guns and fucking Nintendo's, but it kind of goes
从400美元中学到那个教训很好。所以当大支票来的时候，你会想，好吧，我不会再买BB枪了。这是摇滚明星的美妙之处之一。就像你想到像史蒂文·泰勒（Steven Tyler）这样的人。天哪，那家伙有1000万美元，然后1000万美元，然后1000万美元，然后1000万美元。我不知道他是不是在买BB枪和该死的任天堂，但它有点像
like this. But actually when we started making real money, my father, both of my parents were musicians. My dad was a classically trained floutist and my mother sang in acapella groups and stuff. So we love music. Anyway, my dad was also, he was a conservative Republican speech writer on Capitol Hill and at a journalist and a campaign manager. And my mom was a public school teacher, like liberal, cool.
这样。但实际上当我们开始赚真钱时，我父亲，我的父母都是音乐家。我爸爸是古典长笛演奏家，我妈妈在阿卡贝拉合唱团唱歌之类的。所以我们热爱音乐。总之，我爸爸也是，他是国会山的保守派共和党演讲撰稿人，还是记者和竞选经理。我妈妈是公立学校老师，很自由，很酷。
They were very cool. But anyway, so when we first started making money, my dad was like, you know, this isn't going to last, right? And I was like, no, of course. He said, you have to treat every check you make like it's the last one you're ever going to make. He's scared the fucking shit out of me. And I still do this.
他们非常酷。但总之，当我们刚开始赚钱时，我爸爸说，你知道，这不会持续下去，对吧？我说，不，当然。他说，你必须把每一张你赚的支票都当作你这辈子赚的最后一张。他把我吓坏了。我到现在还这么做。
Like I still, everyone I get, I'm like, well, that's it. I guess I'm fucking out. Back to shake his pizza. I'm fucking. Yeah, right, right. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. You like me did not finish high school.
就像我仍然，我得到的每一个，我都想，好吧，就是这样。我想我完蛋了。回到Shakey's Pizza。我他妈的。对，对。我们马上回来。现在回到节目。你像我一样没有完成高中学业。
And that has been one of the things that's sort of driven me to constantly try to stay a few years ahead to make sure I don't run out of employment or, you know, cash or anything. Is there still some part of you that still sort of like, got to stay ahead, got to got to keep this thing going. They're going to kick me out any minute. Always. Yeah.
这一直是驱使我不断尝试保持领先几年，以确保我不会用尽工作，或者，你知道，现金或任何东西的事情之一。是否还有一部分你仍然觉得，必须保持领先，必须让这件事继续下去。他们随时会把我踢出去。总是。对。
I mean, when you like, so my mother raised my sister and I on like the public school teacher salary. Yeah. So it's like month to month. You know what I mean? So I sort of realized at an early age that she was working at the school and Bloomingdales and serve pro carpet cleaning. I'm like, oh shit, you have to work your ass off to stay ahead of it to have food.
我是说，当你，所以我的母亲靠公立学校老师的工资抚养我和我姐姐。对。所以就像月光族。你知道我的意思吗？所以我很早就意识到她在学校、Bloomingdale百货和ServePro地毯清洁公司工作。我当时想，哦该死，你必须拼命工作才能保持领先，才能有食物。
You know, and so Virginia where you grew up. Yeah. Just outside of DC. Yeah. Let me ask you this. What were the bands that you were like, right when you were getting to, I know you talked about Zeppelin and I know we all appreciate, I love those bands and I have an eclectic like people say, I'm like, I'm not a deadhead, but I've seen the dead like 11 times.
你知道，所以弗吉尼亚是你长大的地方。对。就在华盛顿特区外面。对。让我问你这个。你当时喜欢的乐队是什么，我知道你谈到了齐柏林飞艇，我知道我们都欣赏，我喜欢那些乐队，我有一个折衷的，就像人们说的，我不是死忠粉（Deadhead），但我看过死之华（The Dead）大概11次。
Like, but I'm not a deadhead. I think that makes you a deadhead. No, it doesn't. No, it doesn't. I'm pretty sure. I once saw in the same. Were you like spinning and taping and doing a fish fan? No, no, no, no.
就像，但我不是死忠粉。我觉得那让你成为死忠粉。不，不是。不，不是。我很确定。我曾经在同一个。你当时在旋转、录音和做Phish乐队的粉丝吗？不，不，不。
Do you have a tie dye in the closet? Don't fuck your life. I was selling devil sticks out of the back. I actually have you ever worn tie dye short? I mean socks. That's a big one. No, never. But I do.
你的衣柜里有扎染衣服吗？别毁了你的生活。我当时在后面卖恶魔棒。我其实，你穿过扎染短裤吗？我是说袜子。那是个大问题。不，从来没有。但我确实。
In sandals. I have a brand new all black, the Grateful Dead. They do send me. It's a weird story. They, the band sends me stuff sometimes. Anyway, I will say this. I saw within a week, I saw Bob Dylan's and in the Jerry Garcia band, both sing forever young within seven days of each other.
穿着凉鞋。我有一双全新的全黑，感恩而死（Grateful Dead）。他们确实会寄给我。这是一个奇怪的故事。他们，乐队有时会寄给我东西。总之，我会说这个。我在一周内看到，我看到鲍勃·迪伦（Bob Dylan）和杰瑞·加西亚（Jerry Garcia）乐队，都在七天内唱了《永远年轻》（Forever Young）。
Anyway, but my point was this. What kind of music were you? I know I was trying to get into like we're all into a collect. You love Zeppelin. You love, but was there one kind of music that you loved more than any other? Like were you an indie guy? Were you a pop guy? Metal guy.
总之，但我的观点是这个。你是什么样的音乐？我知道我试图进入像我们都喜欢折衷。你喜欢齐柏林飞艇。你喜欢，但有没有一种音乐是你比任何其他音乐都更喜欢的？你是独立音乐人吗？你是流行音乐人吗？金属乐迷。
I was first, I was a Beatles guy. And then I got that rush record with the camel toe and I was afraid to let anyone hear it or know that I was listening to, I hit it like I under my bed. Like it was a playboy. I hit it under the bed. And then, and then I discovered punk rock music. I went up to Chicago. I have these cousins that live in Evanston outside of Chicago.
我首先，我是披头士（Beatles）迷。然后我得到了那张有骆驼趾的Rush唱片，我不敢让任何人听到或知道我在听，我把它藏起来，就像在床底下。就像它是《花花公子》（Playboy）。我把它藏在床底下。然后，然后我发现了朋克摇滚音乐。我去了芝加哥。我有这些住在芝加哥郊外埃文斯顿（Evanston）的表亲。
And we would go up every year from Virginia for. Yeah. Well, I'm from Chicago. I know I was. Oh, there you go. So my cousin Tracy lived in Evanston right off the lake on this. You have a Tracy? I do.
我们每年都会从弗吉尼亚去。对。好吧，我来自芝加哥。我知道我是。哦，原来如此。所以我的表妹特雷西（Tracy）住在埃文斯顿，就在湖边。你有一个特雷西？我有。
Wait a minute. You have a cousin named Tracy in Evanston? I did. Oh, no. She's not dead. She's just in Florida now. But anyway, so anyway, so I went up there and she had turned into a punk rocker. Like we got one summer we show up and she's got like chains and boots and the jacket and
等等。你在埃文斯顿有一个叫特雷西的表妹？我有。哦，不。她没死。她只是现在在佛罗里达。但总之，所以总之，我去了那里，她变成了一个朋克摇滚乐手。就像我们有一个夏天出现，她有链子、靴子、夹克和
the shave head. I was like, I'd only seen that on like Quincy and chips. I'm like, holy fucking shit. This is real. Oh my God. Wait a minute. Yes. The problem child that needs to be rescued.
剃光头。我当时想，我只在像《昆西》（Quincy）和《警网急先锋》（CHiPs）里见过那个。我当时想，该死，这是真的。天哪。等等。是的。需要被拯救的问题儿童。
That night she took me to the first time I ever saw a band was this punk rock band from Chicago called Naked Reagan. Yes, of course. Right. They were playing at the Cubby Bear right across the street from Wrigley Field. Yes, of course. So she took, I was like 13. She took me to the Cubby Bear and I'm like, all I knew about rock and roll was like the
那天晚上她带我去了我第一次看到的乐队，是芝加哥的一支叫Naked Raygun的朋克摇滚乐队。是的，当然。对。他们在瑞格利球场（Wrigley Field）街对面的Cubby Bear演奏。是的，当然。所以她带，我当时大概13岁。她带我去了Cubby Bear，我当时想，我所知道的关于摇滚乐的一切就是像
lasers and the dragons and the castles and the fucking kiss and shit like that. So this was like this tiny shitty little room with the tiny shitty little stage and they had two tiny shitty little lamps and there was a microphone and they started playing and the place fucking exploded and like spit and blood and puke and fucking guys standing on my head and I was like, oh, this is rock and roll. That's pretty wild. So then I fucking dove head first into that whole punk rock thing. But the thing that I loved about it is that all of these bands were totally doing it themselves.
激光、龙、城堡和该死的Kiss乐队之类的东西。所以这是一个又小又烂的房间，有一个又小又烂的舞台，他们有两个又小又烂的灯，有一个麦克风，他们开始演奏，那个地方他妈的爆炸了，就像口水、血、呕吐物和该死的家伙站在我的头上，我当时想，哦，这就是摇滚乐。那太疯狂了。所以我就一头扎进了整个朋克摇滚的东西。但我喜欢它的一点是，所有这些乐队都是完全自己做的。
Like there was no record companies. They had their own record companies and made their own. So you're like Fugazi, like that whole vibe? Like Fugazi. Yeah, like Fugazi. Yeah. That whole scene. Well, that's where I grew up in DC.
就像没有唱片公司。他们有自己的唱片公司，制作自己的。所以你是像Fugazi，像那种氛围？像Fugazi。对，像Fugazi。对。整个场景。好吧，那是我在华盛顿特区长大的地方。
Right. Like those were our friends. The 930 Club? Yeah, the 930 Club. Yeah. So how much time did you spend in Chicago? We'd usually go for like a couple of weeks and then we'd go back home. Yeah.
对。就像那些是我们的朋友。930俱乐部？对，930俱乐部。对。所以你在芝加哥待了多少时间？我们通常会去几个星期，然后我们就回家了。对。
Do you ever go to Medusa's? I did not go to Medusa's. If it's like an ice cream shop or something. What is it? Yeah. So is that where you used to go? Pants Tailor? No.
你去过Medusa's吗？我没去过Medusa's。如果它像一家冰淇淋店之类的。那是什么？对。所以那是你以前去的地方吗？裤子裁缝？不。
So speaking of pants, speaking of the camel toe and everything, once you got off the drum stool and you became lead man, you're up front, was there a pressure to work on the inseam at all? Like when you're up front, do you have to, what is the rock and roll sort of rule there that you, can you wear baggy pants as a... Wait, huh? Yeah. We're talking about...
所以说到裤子，说到骆驼趾和所有东西，一旦你离开鼓凳，成为主唱，你站在前面，有没有压力去处理裤裆？就像当你站在前面时，你必须，摇滚乐的规则是什么，你可以穿宽松的裤子作为……等等，哈？对。我们在谈论……
Can you wear baggy pants as a singer? Yeah. Or do you... Do we have to talk about MC Hammer? This whole podcast? Is that what we're doing? MC Hammer and John Bottom. Go.
你可以穿宽松的裤子作为歌手吗？对。或者你……我们必须谈论MC Hammer吗？整个播客？这就是我们要做的吗？MC Hammer和约翰·博纳姆。说。
Well, I mean, I didn't put that much thought into it. One of the reasons why, okay, so I go and I record that thing by myself. Where? The first record. It was just the first Foo Fighters, it was in Seattle. There was a studio right down the street from my house and I'm like, okay, I need to do something. Right.
好吧，我是说，我没想那么多。原因之一，好吧，所以我去，我自己录了那个东西。哪里？第一张唱片。那只是第一张喷火战机乐队，是在西雅图。离我家那条街有个录音室，我当时想，好吧，我需要做点什么。对。
Because I stopped playing music. I didn't want to become someone else's drummer and I was, you know, our whole world was turned upside down. And you went to Ireland and there's this great story about a hitchhiker there, if you want to share? Yeah. So after Kurt died, everyone just kind of retreated into our corners and we kind of hid from the world.
因为我停止了演奏音乐。我不想成为别人的鼓手，而且我当时，你知道，我们的整个世界都被颠倒了。你去了爱尔兰，关于那里的一个搭车客有一个很棒的故事，如果你想分享的话？对。所以库尔特死后，每个人都退缩到自己的角落，我们有点躲避世界。
And I decided to go on this like soul searching, find the most remote place on earth trip. And I went to the Ring of Kerry in Scotland where I'd been before and I decided I was just going to drive around and think for a while. And I was driving down this country road and I saw a hitchhiker and I thought, well, maybe I'll pick him up. And as I got closer, I saw that he had a Kurt Cobain t-shirt on in the middle of nowhere. And it was in that moment that I'm like, okay, I can't outrun this thing. I need to like, I need to play music.
我决定去进行这种灵魂探索，寻找地球上最偏远的地方的旅行。我去了我以前去过的苏格兰克里郡（Ring of Kerry），我决定我只是要开车到处转转，思考一会儿。我正开在乡间小路上，我看到一个搭车客，我想，好吧，也许我会载他一程。当我靠近时，我看到他在荒郊野外穿着一件库尔特·科本（Kurt Cobain）的T恤。就在那一刻，我想，好吧，我无法逃避这件事。我需要，我需要演奏音乐。
That's wild. And so then I went back and booked six days in this little studio and just recorded the 15 songs by myself thinking, okay, I'm just going to make a cassette and hand it to some friends and what it was not like a career decision. It was like, okay, I'm just going to do this because I felt like I needed to do it. But it made you go, good. I thought you were going to say, so I strangled the guy and I hit him in some bushes. Okay, good.
那太疯狂了。所以然后我回去，在这个小录音室预订了六天，自己录了15首歌，想着，好吧，我只是要做一盘卡带，交给一些朋友，它不是一个职业决定。它就像，好吧，我只是要这样做，因为我觉得我需要这样做。但它让你去，好。我以为你要说，所以我勒死了那个人，把他藏在灌木丛里。好吧，好。
You did not do that. That did not happen. Okay, good, good. Fuck no. Fuck out of there as fast as I could. Man, that album is so great as all the ones that followed have been as well. But that was kind of your like, you realized that like you had to kind of, I love that idea, like that headspace that you're in that you're like, you're like, okay, universe,
你没那么做。那没发生。好吧，好，好。该死，不。以我能有的最快速度离开那里。伙计，那张专辑太棒了，随后的所有专辑也一样。但那有点像你的，你意识到你必须，我喜欢那个想法，你所处的那个心态，你就像，你就像，好吧，宇宙，
I hear you, motherfucker, I'll go, I'll do it. I'll jump back in. Just steer right into it. Well, I mean, if you think about it, like your entire life, listen, in the darkest moments of your life, you've probably turned to music and listened to music to help heal whatever you feel. 100%. So I kind of went in that, at first I'd stopped listening to music and then I'm like, no,
我听到了，混蛋，我会去，我会做的。我会跳回去。直接冲进去。好吧，我是说，如果你想一想，就像你的一生，听着，在你生命中最黑暗的时刻，你可能转向音乐并听音乐来帮助治愈你的任何感受。100%。所以我有点进入那个，起初我停止听音乐，然后我想，不，
wait, it's kind of healed me my whole life. Now I need to like get back into it. Right. 100%. I get that. Was it transitioning off of the drum set and going upfront and finding Taylor and kind of handing that off? It's a drum kit, by the way.
等等，它治愈了我的一生。现在我需要，我需要回到它。对。100%。我明白了。从鼓组过渡并走到前面，找到泰勒并把它交出去？顺便说一句，那是鼓组（drum kit）。
It's a drum kit. Sorry. Yeah. So the whole thing, did you want to sing and play guitar and be upfront or was it, what was that decision process? No, it was totally weird and foreign and I hated it, but that's kind of why I did it because I didn't want to just go sit and play the drums some more because I kind of knew I could do that, but this was something I didn't know that I could do.
那是鼓组。抱歉。对。所以整个事情，你想唱歌、弹吉他并站在前面，还是，那个决策过程是什么？不，那完全奇怪且陌生，我讨厌它，但这正是为什么我这样做的原因，因为我不想只是去坐着再打鼓，因为我有点知道我能做到，但这东西是我不知道我能做到的。
And you had some things you wanted to say, yeah, with writing lyrics and... My lyrics are fucking terrible. I said absolutely nothing at all for the first 10 years. Maybe the last record, I actually said something meaningful. Are you conscious of that when you're writing, I'm not agreeing with you, but when you're writing lyrics, you're like, I'm not even going to try to do anything somewhat profound. I remember spending so much time on the lyric once and our bass player Nate said, dude, not every song has to be imagined.
而且你有一些想说的话，是的，关于写歌词和……我的歌词太烂了。前10年我什么都没说。也许最后一张唱片，我确实说了一些有意义的话。当你写歌词时，你意识到这一点吗，我不同意你的观点，但当你写歌词时，你就像，我甚至不会尝试做任何有点深刻的事情。我记得有一次花了很多时间在歌词上，我们的贝斯手内特（Nate）说，伙计，不是每一首歌都必须是《想象》（Imagine）。
You know that, right? And so then I was like, really? Yeah. I was like a fucking bullshit. Right. Wow. Can we go back? So who was the floutest, your dad or your mom?
你知道那个，对吧？然后我就想，真的吗？对。我当时就像个该死的废话。对。哇。我们能回去吗？所以谁是长笛演奏家，你爸爸还是你妈妈？
Dad. My dad. Did they encourage you to study music and to learn music theory and things like that? Or are you just by ear? I just kind of went by ear. There was this old guitar in the corner of our house and I felt like around nine years old, I picked it up and I was one string, I'm like, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam. I'm like, oh shit, this is easy.
爸爸。我的爸爸。他们有没有鼓励你去学音乐、学乐理之类的东西？还是说你全凭耳感？我基本上是凭耳感。我们家角落里有一把旧吉他，我大概九岁的时候拿起来，就拨弄一根弦，砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰。我就想，噢该死，这太简单了。
Yeah. And then I just fucking... Wow. And then I had lessons and I had this Beatles songbook and we play a lot of Beatles stuff. But drums, I would set up pillows in my bedroom on the floor and learn how to then put on records and do it that way. Does any part of you want to go learn, not that you have to because you're brilliant, but go back and kind of learn all of the, how to read music and how, and the music theory
是啊。然后我就……哇。后来我上过课，有一本披头士的歌集，我们经常弹披头士的歌。至于鼓，我会把枕头摆在卧室地板上，然后放唱片跟着学。你有没有哪一部分想去学习一下——不是说你必须学，因为你已经很厉害了——但想回去学学怎么读谱，还有乐理知识？
of it and chord progressions and time signatures and all that kind of stuff? Oh god, that sounds like a lot of fun. Yeah. No. There is no part of me that wants to do... Yeah, now that you've got a lot of money and time to do whatever you want, do you want to go into the recent boring shit? Fuck that.
比如和弦进行、拍号之类的东西？天哪，听起来很有趣。是啊。我一点都不想做……是啊，现在你有钱又有时间做任何你想做的事，你想去钻研那些无聊的东西吗？去他的。
You know, I actually had a plan when I was young. I was like, okay, since I'll never become a professional musician, I should learn how to read music and I'll become a studio drummer and then I'll make enough money that I could put myself back through school and then get a real job. Yeah, right. Right. And then I was like, fuck that. Can I ask a dumb question?
你知道吗，我年轻时其实有个计划。我想，好吧，既然我永远成不了职业音乐人，我就该学学读谱，然后去当个录音室鼓手，赚够钱后再回去读书，找份正经工作。是啊，没错。对。然后我就想，去他的。我能问个蠢问题吗？
Can you read drum music? Do drums have notes? Yeah, they do and they look like squiggly little lines. I don't get it. They're X's, where the notes are. They're just X's. Okay, Sean, like let's learn how to play some drums right now. Sean, very studied.
你会看鼓谱吗？鼓有音符吗？有的，它们看起来像弯弯曲曲的小线条。我不明白。音符所在的地方是叉号。它们只是叉号。好吧，肖恩，咱们现在就学学怎么打鼓吧。肖恩，非常用功。
Sean, that's what he's talking about with this. Maybe you can teach me to play the drums as well. Tap dancing, drumming. Yeah, if you got some extra time. Dave, he's trying to get you to, he's trying to identify, he's working towards, ask him Sean about musicals. Fucking ask him. No, no.
肖恩，他说的就是这个。也许你也能教我打鼓。踢踏舞、打鼓。是啊，如果你有空的话。戴夫，他想让你……他想确认一下，他正准备问你关于音乐剧的事。快问他。不，不。
Just do it. I do have another question though about genres of music because there are certain genres of music. Have you seen promises, promises? Have you, is there a certain genre of music that you aren't drawn to? Like, you know, there's so many. There's country, there's pop, there's rock, there's rap, there's just tons and tons. Is there something that you're like, eh, that's not for me?
问吧。不过我还有个关于音乐流派的问题，因为有些音乐流派……你看过《承诺，承诺》吗？有没有哪个音乐流派是你不太感兴趣的？你知道，流派太多了。有乡村音乐、流行音乐、摇滚乐、说唱，多得数不清。有没有什么让你觉得“呃，那不适合我”的？
I'm not the biggest country fan. I have to be honest. Good for you. There's certain things that I kind of like and there's certain artists that I respect and think are really great. Maybe you and I can get together and watch a Ken Burns documentary on country and get to know it and get to know it. Should we do that?
说实话，我不是乡村音乐的超级粉丝。你说得对。有些东西我还是挺喜欢的，也有一些我很尊敬、觉得非常棒的艺术家。也许我们可以一起看肯·伯恩斯的乡村音乐纪录片，去了解一下。我们要看吗？
Yeah. Should we go? I mean, I went to, like I did this HBO series called Sonic Highways and I went to Nashville and did a whole episode on Nashville and it was really interesting and of course, like, Nashville's, that's the town with the best musicians. That's the place where you walk down the street, look in someone's window and they're playing like a dulcimer or something like that. That place is filled with the most brilliant musicians.
好啊。我们要去吗？我是说，我拍过一部HBO的系列片叫《音速公路》，我去过纳什维尔，还专门拍了一集关于纳什维尔的内容，真的很有趣。当然，纳什维尔是拥有最棒音乐人的城市。在那儿，你走在街上，往别人窗户里看，他们可能正在弹扬琴之类的乐器。那个地方到处都是最天才的音乐人。
I don't know why. It's just, I've just never clicked with the country. Tell me how you like or not like the being sort of the frontman, the leader, the dad in the band. The dad. Well, but I mean, you know, I put it together and he's the boss and how do you like managing the inevitable ups and downs of traveling and living together and probably spending more time with one another than your actual family?
我不知道为什么。我就是对乡村音乐没感觉。跟我说说你喜不喜欢当乐队主唱、领队、乐队里的“爸爸”这种感觉？“爸爸”。嗯，我是说，你知道，是我组建了乐队，他是老板，你觉得管理乐队巡演和共同生活带来的不可避免的起起落落，以及可能比陪家人还多的相处时间，感觉如何？
Hang on. Before you answer, sorry, Jason, I just want to get you up and just say, or the mom, just because, just to cut off all, you know, to head off the letters we're going to get. He needs to be mom too. You know, there's mom. It's such a dummy. Wow. Will's policing this whole thing.
等等。在你回答之前，抱歉，杰森，我只是想让你加上，或者说“妈妈”，就为了……为了堵住我们要收到的那些信。他得当妈妈才行。你知道，还有妈妈。真是个笨蛋。哇。威尔在监管这一切。
Yeah. That's a bad sign. That's not cool. Yeah. That's like me being the front person of a band. Bad. Bad idea. But are you good at smoothing out conflict and doing all the administrative stuff that
是啊。这是个坏兆头。这可不酷。是啊。这就像让我去当乐队主唱一样。糟糕。坏主意。但你擅长化解冲突和处理乐队里那些行政琐事吗？
one needs to do in a band or not? Well, we've been a band for 26 years, which is amazing. It's 26 years. That's great. It's just that eventually you come up with some sort of system that works. And I always liken it to like wheels and a clock. There's like the big wheel that rolls slow. There's a little wheel that kind of does this.
嗯，我们组建乐队26年了，这很了不起。26年了。太棒了。只是最终你会找到一套行之有效的系统。我总是把它比作时钟里的齿轮。有一个转得很慢的大齿轮，还有一个转得很快的小齿轮。
And when the gears meet, like that keeps ticking. And so, you know, I like to be in a band, right? Right. Like I like it when everybody is there for the same reason and everyone's contributing and it's really awesome. Do I have to make like sort of weird decisions, tough decisions sometimes? Yes. But I refer to different members for certain things.
当齿轮咬合时，它就会一直走。所以，你知道，我喜欢待在乐队里，对吧？对。我喜欢每个人都为了同一个目标，每个人都在贡献，这真的很棒。我有时需要做一些奇怪的、艰难的决定吗？是的。但我会就某些事情咨询其他成员。
Like if I have a sort of like a, any sort of like ethical dilemma or crisis, I turn to Nate and Pat and I'm like, what should we do? They're like the barometer. If it's, if we need to have like a stadium rock ending to a song, I turn to Taylor and I'm like, Taylor, what would Queen do? You know, so. What about T-shirt designs? Who's got, who's got?
比如如果我遇到任何道德困境或危机，我会去问内特和帕特，我会问：我们该怎么办？他们就像气压计。如果我们需要给一首歌加一个体育场摇滚式的结尾，我会去问泰勒：泰勒，皇后乐队会怎么做？你知道，就是这样。那T恤设计呢？谁负责？
Never me. T-shirt. Absolutely not. Never, never, never me. Really? No. Who's got the taste on the graphic art? It's probably like Nate and Chris.
从来不是我。T恤。绝对不是。从来、从来、从来不是我。真的吗？不。谁对平面设计有品位？可能是内特和克里斯。
And you know what, to be honest, I don't fucking care. So I just kind of back out and go like, yeah, whatever you guys want to do, I don't fucking care. You don't care for real? When it comes to album covers and shit, yes. We haven't done a coffee cup for a while or what about a good key fob? You're not, you're not. Yeah, that's an email that I swipe and delete.
说实话，我根本不在乎。所以我通常会退后一步说：好吧，你们想怎么弄都行，我一点都不在乎。你真的不在乎？说到专辑封面之类的东西，是的。我们好久没做咖啡杯了，或者钥匙扣怎么样？你不是……你不是。是啊，那是那种我会直接划掉删除的邮件。
By the way, those are Bateman's best ideas, coffee cup and a fucking key fob. God, I designed the greatest key fob. Look at the, he's aesthetically inclined, he's just taking a look. This looks like just a generic hoodie. It's $6,000. By the way, we should mention, this is a great time to mention because we've never mentioned it except for when we do have a hoodie, we have a website, I just thought about that this week.
顺便说一下，那些是贝特曼最好的点子，咖啡杯和该死的钥匙扣。天哪，我设计了最棒的钥匙扣。看看，他很有审美，他只是看了一眼。这看起来就像一件普通的连帽衫。要6000美元。顺便提一下，现在是个好时机，因为我们除了有连帽衫的时候，从来没提过我们有个网站，我这周才想到。
We have a website. Oh, you have merch. And we have merch. We've never talked about it. Cool. Go to foodfighters.com. Foodfighters.com. Yeah, it's weird that we're selling ourselves at foodfighters.com.
我们有个网站。噢，你们有周边商品。我们有周边。我们从来没谈过这个。酷。去foodfighters.com看看。Foodfighters.com。是啊，我们在foodfighters.com上卖我们自己，这挺奇怪的。
Dave, when you were growing up, it's clear that you kind of, you know, took influence from your dad and the music side and a lot of kids either go one way or the other, right? You go, oh, I want to do what my parents do or I don't, I want to run from what my parents did. Is what about your kids? Is anybody kind of... In your case, your parents just run. Right.
戴夫，你成长过程中，很明显你受到了你父亲在音乐方面的影响，很多孩子要么走这条路，要么走那条路，对吧？你会说，噢，我想做我父母做的事，或者我想逃离我父母做过的事。你的孩子们呢？有没有人……在你这个案例里，你父母只是跑了。对。
Sorry. Not your dad, but keep going, Sean, sorry. And I stayed put and got fat, but anyway, but is what about your kids? They want to do it, dad? Does they run or run? Well, my daughter Violet, who's 15, she is the most talented musician that this family has ever known. Oh, that's cool.
抱歉。不是你爸爸，继续说，肖恩，抱歉。我留下来还变胖了，但不管怎样，你的孩子们呢？他们想做这行吗，爸爸？他们是想逃离还是……嗯，我15岁的女儿维奥莱特，她是这个家里最有天赋的音乐人。噢，那太酷了。
Like she has perfect pitch and she has like an incredible memory, musical memory. She could pick up an instrument and learn it in like a week. She's a total badass. Does she think you're a badass or does she think, oh, he's dad, he sucks. He's a dad-ass. No, I think she, you know, she's grown up like, you know, I've been carrying her backstage since she was, you know, so she's seen this whole thing like from the ground up. She gets that you're good, that you're not just screwing around.
她有绝对音感，还有惊人的音乐记忆力。她拿起一件乐器，一周内就能学会。她真是个狠角色。她觉得你是个狠角色，还是觉得“噢，他就是个爸爸，他烂透了”？他是个“爸爸级”人物。不，我觉得她……你知道，她从小就……我从她很小的时候就带她去后台，所以她从底层见证了这一切。她明白你很厉害，不是在瞎胡闹。
Well, she gets that I work really hard at trying to make good records and stuff like that. And that's a big part of it. How does she handle all the travel? I mean, she doesn't know any different, hopefully, like my kids, like they just kind of deal with it and I don't see any problems yet, but how does the family deal with you being gone all the time? Well, you know, she's actually, she's one of our backup singers now.
嗯，她明白我在努力制作好的唱片之类的。这很重要。她怎么处理所有的旅行？我是说，她不知道别的生活方式，希望像我的孩子们一样，他们只是顺其自然，我还没看到什么问题，但家人怎么看待你总是离家在外？嗯，你知道，她现在其实是我们的一名伴唱。
Oh, great. So she comes on the road and we like, we share a room. She's like on that side of the suite. How old is she? I'm on this 15 and a half. On this side of the suite, wake up in the morning and I like order room service and I'm like, it's time to get up and then we like have some breakfast and then we roll our bags down to the thing, then we go to the thing, 100,000 people, then we go, we get a pizza
噢，太棒了。所以她会跟我们一起巡演，我们住一个套房。她在那边。她多大了？我在这边，15岁半。在套房的这边，早上醒来，我点客房服务，我说：该起床了，然后我们吃点早餐，然后我们拖着行李去那个地方，然后我们去那个地方，10万人的现场，然后我们去吃披萨，
and then we watch a horror movie and it's actually really awesome. And then my daughter Harper, she came up to me when she was like nine or something like that. And she said, I want to learn how to play the drums and I'm like, drums, like that's some fucking mail room positioned shit. Really? Like straight to the drums, usually you get demoted. And so I was like, okay, so I started showing her how to play the drums and she has like
然后我们看恐怖电影，这其实真的很棒。然后我的女儿哈珀，她大概九岁的时候跑来找我，她说：我想学打鼓。我说：打鼓？那可是收发室那种级别的活儿。真的吗？直接学打鼓，通常这算降职。所以我说：好吧，于是我开始教她打鼓，她有一种
an internal meter where she's got really good time and she understands how that shit works. And I sat her down and gave her an AC DC record and she was like, she has feel like she's really got it. She did it for like three months and was just like, fuck that. By the way, that was really good already. Did you show her the videos of Nandi Bushall? Oh yeah. Well, you know what?
内在的节奏感，她对节拍把握得很好，她明白那玩意儿是怎么运作的。我让她坐下，给了她一张AC/DC的唱片，她就像……她很有感觉，她真的很有天赋。她练了大概三个月，然后就说：去他的。顺便说一下，她已经很厉害了。你给她看过南迪·布沙尔的视频吗？噢，当然。你知道吗？
They're actually my daughters. I wrote a song for Nandi and my three daughters were the backup singers for the song that I wrote for Nandi. Oh, that was that girl, that English girl that you got into the thing with? Yes. That was so real. That was so, so real. I have a question about what you just did, because that was kind of mind blowing, what
她们其实是我的女儿。我为南迪写了一首歌，我的三个女儿是我为南迪写的那首歌的伴唱。噢，就是那个你跟她杠上的英国女孩？是的。那太真实了。太真实了。我有个关于你刚才所做之事的问题，因为那太令人震撼了，你刚才……
you just like, Will just said, that was crazy. The thing about drummers is that is like this internal thing, how do you learn how to, I mean, it's you keeping the rhythm for the whole song, for the whole show all the time, every song. And how do you learn how to do that? You know, I'll tell you, when I was a kid, like when we would, my grandparents lived in Ohio and we would drive from Springfield up to Youngstown, Ohio. And when you pass through Pennsylvania, you're going through all of those tunnels through
威尔刚才说，那太疯狂了。鼓手的问题在于，这是一种内在的东西，你是怎么学会……我是说，你得在整首歌、整场演出中一直保持节奏。你是怎么学会的？我告诉你，我小时候，我祖父母住在俄亥俄州，我们会从斯普林菲尔德开车去俄亥俄州的扬斯敦。当你经过宾夕法尼亚州时，你会穿过所有那些隧道，穿过
the mountains and stuff. So you have a radio station on and there's a song is like, and then you go into the tunnel and it's gone and you try to keep time with it. So when you come out, it's like, battle, battle, battle, battle, battle, battle, battle, battle. So I would do this game in the fucking tunnels to see if I could actually keep the meter going like that. And so I did that my whole entire life. But all joking aside, and the tap dancing, I never joke about that.
山脉之类的。所以你开着收音机，有一首歌在放，然后你进入隧道，声音没了，你试着保持节奏。所以当你出来时，就像：砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰。所以我会在那些该死的隧道里玩这个游戏，看看我能不能真的保持住那个节拍。我这辈子一直都在这么做。但抛开玩笑，还有踢踏舞，我从不拿那个开玩笑。
That's no joke. You have to be. You have to be a good dancer because not that you've tried maybe or I don't know, because it's your whole body is rhythm. Yeah. But that's kind of the last thing you want to see from anyone on a dance floor because I'm either going to like do the fucking robot or it looks like a dead head like will or it's like it's not.
那不是开玩笑。你必须得是个好舞者，因为……不是说你可能试过，或者我不知道，因为你的全身都是节奏。是啊。但那是你在舞池里最不想从任何人身上看到的东西，因为我要么会跳那种该死的机器人舞，要么看起来像个像威尔那样的死脑筋，或者……那不是。
I don't know. But how is that? How is that? How is the rhythm, the internal rhythm, the clock that you have? How is it, you know, shown up in other parts of life? You know, I could play drums with my teeth. You can. What does that look like?
我不知道。但那是怎样的？那是怎样的？那种节奏，内在的节奏，你拥有的那个时钟，它是怎么在生活的其他部分体现出来的？你知道，我可以用牙齿打鼓。你可以。那看起来是什么样？
Let me see if I can. I can do this with my with my mouth and my nose by breath. I can go. Oh, I heard that. That was cool. I was like, check it. Yeah. It was a little bossa nova.
让我看看我能不能。我可以用我的嘴和鼻子呼吸来做到。我可以发出……噢，我听到了。那很酷。我就像，瞧。是啊。那有点波萨诺瓦风格。
Yeah. Wait, do you do blow? Do I do blow? No, I don't. She's still, yeah. Hey, he really should dry it though. Yeah. It's real fun.
是啊。等等，你吸毒吗？我吸毒吗？不，我不吸。她还在，是啊。嘿，他真的应该把它擦干。是啊。这真有趣。
Sorry. That's just an aside. So, hey, Sean, Sean, did you do that because you wanted to try to figure out how to smell your own breath? Do any of you guys know how to smell your own breath? I'm sorry, what's the question, idiot? Sorry, I just want to double back on the camel toe question for Dave
抱歉。那只是个题外话。嘿，肖恩，肖恩，你做那个是因为你想弄清楚怎么闻自己的呼吸吗？你们谁知道怎么闻自己的呼吸吗？抱歉，问题是什么，白痴？抱歉，我只是想回到戴夫的骆驼趾问题上，
and then when I want to get to breath smelling, I'm kidding. Guys, I'm the best host of the year. What about these questions? What about these questions? I had a joke that I was gonna make that even I wouldn't make, so I didn't make it. Do it, we can cut it, go.
然后我想谈谈闻呼吸的事，开个玩笑。伙计们，我是年度最佳主持人。这些问题怎么样？这些问题怎么样？我本来有个笑话想讲，连我自己都不会讲，所以我没讲。讲吧，我们可以剪掉，来。
No, I'm not gonna do it. Really? No, I actually have a line. All right. Okay, Dave, what about directing? Do you have a passion for that? Or is it just like, ah, fuck it, I'm tired of listening to these guys direct our videos.
不，我不讲了。真的吗？不，我其实有底线。好吧。好吧，戴夫，导演工作怎么样？你有热情吗？还是说只是因为：啊，去他的，我厌倦了听这些人指导我们的视频。
I'll tell where to point the camera and stuff like that. Or do you have a passion for that? Well, most of the videos that we've done, like I have come from crazy dreams that I've had. And so, and we would look through all the treatments, people would send us and I'd be like, man, what doesn't really, man, and then I would write a treatment
我会告诉他们把摄像机对准哪里之类的。还是说你对此有热情？嗯，我们拍的大多数视频，都是源于我做过的疯狂梦境。所以，我们会看人们发给我们的所有方案，我会说：伙计，这不太……伙计，然后我会写一个方案，
and someone would say, do you want to direct it? And I'd say, I have no idea how to do that. And then I would do it. And so I've done it a bunch of times. And then the documentary stuff, like that stuff just kind of fell into my lap. And that's really fun. I really enjoy doing that.
然后有人会问：你想导演它吗？我会说：我根本不知道怎么做。然后我就做了。所以我做过很多次。然后纪录片那些东西，就像是天上掉下来的。那真的很有趣。我真的很享受做那个。
Who are the musicians now? And all jokes aside from going like, you know, like Elvis Presley, like who are the people you would like to, who are still making music or have been making music in the last 25 years, current recording artists that you're like, or that you would like to make a record with or you think is fucking cool or doing something that's cool.
现在的音乐人是谁？抛开像埃尔维斯·普雷斯利这种玩笑话，谁是你愿意……谁是过去25年里还在做音乐或一直在做音乐的、现在的录音艺术家，你想和他们一起录唱片，或者你觉得很酷、正在做很酷的事情的人？
And I don't mean like, I want to do with Justin Bieber, like forget the mainstream. And I don't want to hear the ironic answer. Tell me the real answer, not like the thing that you think will, you know what I mean? Yeah. I know I've met a lot of really amazing musicians. I'm sure everybody, you've met everybody,
我不是说像“我想和贾斯汀·比伯合作”那种，忘了主流吧。我不想听那种讽刺的回答。告诉我真实的答案，不是那种你觉得威尔会……你知道我的意思吗？是啊。我知道，我见过很多非常了不起的音乐人。我相信每个人，你见过所有人，
like Steve Malchemist, like somebody like that. Like he's one of the most- Well, I'm more like Omar Hakeem and Nile Roger and Greg Kirsten and like just like assemble like a real like bad ass group of people to go in the studio for one week and then just like bang some stuff out and see what happens. That's really fun. Cause when you meet musicians
比如史蒂夫·马尔克穆斯，像那样的人。他是最……嗯，我更倾向于奥马尔·哈基姆、奈尔·罗杰斯和格雷格·科斯汀，就像召集一群真正厉害的人，在录音室待上一周，然后搞出点东西，看看会发生什么。那真的很有趣。因为当你遇到
that you've never really played with before, you meet someone and you try to carry conversation and you try to like make friends this way. But when you put on instruments as musicians, like those conversations can be more fun and deeper. When there's no language, you're just like playing the music together. That's really awesome.
你从未真正合作过的音乐人时，你遇到某人，你试着交谈，你试着这样交朋友。但当你作为音乐人拿起乐器时，那些对话会更有趣、更深刻。当没有语言时，你们只是在一起演奏音乐。那真的太棒了。
Cause then you almost, you find out what type of person they are by the way that they play their instruments. So that's why I love jamming with so many different people is that it's like, you know, once you sit down and start doing it, you're like, oh, that's who you are. Oh, okay, cool.
因为那时你几乎可以通过他们演奏乐器的方式发现他们是什么样的人。这就是为什么我喜欢和这么多不同的人即兴演奏，因为你知道，一旦你坐下来开始演奏，你就会想：噢，原来你是这样的人。噢，好的，酷。
I tried to make a conversation with Dave once during some of my, my, my, before I lost my privileges. This one I was really thirsty during my peak drinking. Sure. I was over at, I think it was Trader Vicks in Beverly Hills. Oh my God.
我曾经在我的……在我失去特权之前，试着和戴夫交谈过。那次我在酗酒高峰期时真的很渴。当然。我当时在比佛利山的Trader Vicks。噢，天哪。
You know- How psyched was he when you- Yeah, well, hold on. Yeah, he let me know. I was deep into my third scorpion bowl and there's Dave Grohl sitting in a booth. And I had just learned that we share the same birthday and year.
你知道……当你在……时他有多兴奋？是啊，好吧，等等。是啊，他让我知道了。我当时正沉浸在我的第三杯蝎子碗里，戴夫·格罗尔坐在卡座里。我刚得知我们是同一天生日，同一年出生。
And I just thought he would be thrilled to learn this too. I am, I have been. No, no, but- Remember the time we had the birthday show at the forum? I was so excited for us to share an arena concert. But this was- Celebrating our birthdays. But this was my first, this is my, my, my passion for you
我当时觉得他得知这个消息也会很激动。我一直都很激动。不，不，但是……还记得我们在论坛举办的那场生日演出吗？我当时很兴奋我们能共享一场体育场演唱会。但那是……庆祝我们的生日。但那是我的第一次，这是我的……我对你的热情
was running white, hot. I'd never met you before and there he is. And I just learned we share the same birthday. So what, that's no wonder why I think this guy's so amazing. So I slide into the booth next to him and I just give him the eyebrows and I say, hey, guess who's got the same birthday as me? Same year.
当时正处于白热化。我以前从没见过你，然后他就坐在那儿。我刚得知我们是同一天生日。难怪我觉得这家伙这么了不起。所以我滑进他旁边的卡座，对他挑了挑眉毛说：嘿，猜猜谁跟我同一天生日？同一年。
Just smiling at him, waiting for a like a fucking what? And he looked at me. I did, this is all, did my, my drunk memory. I'm sure he was very, very nice, but I just remembered just whatever the physical facial equivalent of crickets is, I got it. Now that's pretty spot on. That's pretty spot on what you're describing.
只是对他笑着，等着一个“该死的，什么？”的反应。他看着我。我确实……这是我喝醉后的记忆。我相信他当时非常、非常友善，但我只记得……无论蟋蟀叫声的表情是什么样的，我得到了那个反应。那描述得相当准确。那描述得相当准确。
It was, right? Yeah, pretty much. I can't see Jason's face. So fucking what, Jason Bateman? I'm here, right? How crazy is this? We'll be right back. All right, back to the show.
是吧？是啊，差不多。我看不到杰森的脸。去他的，杰森·贝特曼？我在这儿，对吧？这有多疯狂？我们马上回来。好了，回到节目。
Are you always someone who kind of, cause you are, you seem, if so much energy, you're super funny, you're always writing, you're always making, creating something. Are you that kind of personality? It just goes, goes, goes all the time. And if so, how do you relax? How do you calm down?
你一直是个……因为你看起来，精力充沛，你超级有趣，你一直在写作，一直在制作，一直在创造什么东西。你是那种性格吗？一直不停地运转？如果是这样，你怎么放松？你怎么冷静下来？
What calms your brain down? Or no, you're just- White claw. White claw. No, yes, I'm a total spaz. That's the short answer. What do I do to relax? Is there anything that calms you down?
什么能让你的大脑冷静下来？还是说，你只是……白爪气泡酒。白爪。不，是的，我完全是个疯子。这是简短的回答。我做什么来放松？有什么能让你冷静下来吗？
I don't know. I don't have any hobbies. I don't know. What, or do you go to the, like, no, you don't work out? Let's, come work out with me, Dave. Come over to the house. No. Yeah, no.
我不知道。我没有任何爱好。我不知道。什么，或者你去……不，你不锻炼？来吧，跟我一起锻炼，戴夫。来我家。不。是啊，不。
Dave, are you, are you a spaz all day? Or are you like me? Yes. Cause we are the same age. Do you crash? Yeah, at like four o'clock. Is it a testosterone thing? Is it a-
戴夫，你整天都是个疯子吗？还是说你像我一样？是的。因为我们年纪一样。你会崩溃吗？是啊，大概在四点钟左右。这是睾酮的问题吗？是……
You might want to get your thyroid checked. Are you napping at all now, dad? I'm a bad napper. No, not a good napper. No, not good. No, I pretty much spaz all day. I, you know, it kind of ramps up around, what time is it?
你可能想去检查一下甲状腺。爸爸，你现在午睡吗？我不擅长午睡。不，不是个好的午睡者。不，不好。不，我整天基本上都在发疯。我，你知道，它大概在……几点了？
10, 11 o'clock in the morning. Yeah. Peak. And then it peaks spaz and then it kind of dips a little bit. Let me ask you guys, like a- And then the white claw. A really dark week stream is a good sign, right?
早上10点、11点左右开始加速。是啊。达到顶峰。然后达到疯狂的顶峰，然后稍微回落一点。让我问问你们，像一个……然后是白爪。深色且微弱的尿流是个好迹象，对吧？
Yes, especially if it smells like maple syrup. I think that's what you're referring to, right? Just checking. I'm healthy. Dave, dark and weak. I love it. Dark week stream. Dave, but we do, I do want to know though, like,
是的，特别是如果它闻起来像枫糖浆的话。我想你指的是那个，对吧？只是确认一下。我很健康。戴夫，深色且微弱。我喜欢。深色微弱的尿流。戴夫，但我确实想知道，
is it like, are you a bass, do you watch baseball? Or do you anything like that? No, I don't watch sports. No. Okay, you don't watch sports? No. The closest thing I had to sports was, I was on a skeet shooting league for a while.
比如，你喜欢棒球吗？或者类似的东西？不，我不看体育节目。不。好吧，你不看体育节目？不。我最接近体育运动的经历是，我曾经参加过一段时间的飞碟射击联盟。
That's pretty- It's pretty fun. That's like- That's pretty dope as hell. That's my sport. With Skeeter. Like, Skeeter. How often are you playing music?
那挺……那挺有趣的。那就像……那真是太酷了。那是我的运动。和斯基特一起。就像，斯基特。你多久演奏一次音乐？
Is it every day in some capacity? You're picking up and just kind of like, noodling around on the guitar, looking for a rhythm that might become a song? That happens kind of every day. But- What do you listen to in the car? Do you have a radio? Do you listen to radio at all, ever?
是每天都在某种程度上吗？你会拿起吉他随便弹弹，寻找可能成为一首歌的节奏吗？那几乎每天都会发生。但是……你在车里听什么？你有收音机吗？你听收音机吗，哪怕一次？
I do. I listen to old school. First of all, like, just the fact that I'm on a computer right now with the thing that's connected to this other thing, all this, is a fucking miracle. I'm the most, like, Not tech chef. AM radio analog dude.
我听。我听老派的。首先，仅仅是我现在正用一台连接着另一个东西的电脑，所有这些，就是一个该死的奇迹。我是最……不是科技达人。AM收音机模拟老派男。
I drive around in the car. I listen to KLOS or whatever. You do? And I hear like Fog Hat again. And I still like it. And yeah. Or, you know, I'm also a YouTuber. So I'll wind up watching videos of songs.
我开车到处跑。我听KLOS之类的。你听吗？我听到像Fog Hat的歌。我依然喜欢它。是啊。或者，你知道，我也是个YouTube用户。所以我最终会看歌曲的视频。
Like I just, the other day, remember that they might be giant song. Put a little birdhouse in your soul. Yes, it's one of my favorite groups. Well, I hadn't listened to them in like 30 years. And in the last 12 hours, I've listened to that song like 1200 times. It's the best.
比如前几天，还记得那首“他们可能是巨人”的歌吗？《把小鸟屋放在你的灵魂里》。是的，那是我最喜欢的乐队之一。嗯，我已经有30年没听他们的歌了。在过去的12个小时里，我听了那首歌大概1200遍。那是最好的。
I love all of it. It's amazing. Like I'm even watching like covers that people have done of, you know, whatever. Yeah. What about this sort of this move away from, it's happening over the last 10 years, probably 15 years, away from real drums,
我喜欢这一切。太神奇了。我甚至在看人们翻唱的视频，你知道，什么的。是啊。关于这种……过去10年，大概15年里发生的，远离真实鼓点、
real guitar, real everything. And it's becoming much more sort of electronic. And you can kind of make a whole album on a computer. Really last 10 years. Have you ever heard Soft Cell? Yeah. Come on, man. No, but I mean, you know what I mean?
真实吉他、真实一切的趋势，变得越来越电子化。你可以在电脑上制作整张专辑。真的过去10年吗？你听过Soft Cell吗？是啊。得了吧，伙计。不，但我是说，你知道我的意思吗？
What is it, 2011 right now? What are you talking about? What? But like, there's no more like amps. And there are like, remember the last time, I mean, there are moments where you see it sort of poking its head into mainstream music. First of all, it's not like a meteor crash
现在是2011年吗？你在说什么？什么？但就像，没有更多的音箱了。而且有……记得上次，我是说，有些时刻你会看到它探头进入主流音乐。首先，这不像陨石撞击
dinosaur extinction level event. It's like guitars and drums. Thanks to you guys and a couple of other bands, you guys are keeping that thing going strong. But you know, like the day is like, the new band used to be, you know, like white stripes or something that's just like hardcore. But now it's like anything that's like, yeah,
恐龙灭绝级别的事件。这就像吉他和鼓。多亏了你们和另外几个乐队，你们让那种东西保持强劲。但你知道，就像现在的乐队过去常常是，你知道，像白线条乐队或者那种纯硬核的。但现在就像任何东西，是啊，
but like super techno, electronic, odd, you try to find a rhythm and you can't is sort of the new, some of the new sort of. I mean, it's also very cyclical. Well, something will be really, really popular for a while. And then that becomes like, oh wow, they're using guitars and drums. Like if you look at, I mean, first of all,
但像超级电音、电子、奇怪，你试着找节奏却找不到，这是新的一种……我是说，这也是非常周期性的。嗯，有些东西会流行很长一段时间。然后那就会变成：噢哇，他们在用吉他和鼓。如果你看，我是说，首先，
Miley Cyrus is like becoming the next Joan Jett as we speak, like this is really happening. Yeah. I mean, she goes out and she's like a rock star, you know? Or like when Lady Gaga played on the Grammys a few years ago, like instead of doing her huge production, she was like, it was almost like she was Ziggy Stardust. She was like singing with the band behind her.
麦莉·赛勒斯正在成为下一个琼·杰特，这真的在发生。是啊。我是说，她走出来，她就像个摇滚明星，你知道吗？或者像Lady Gaga几年前在格莱美上表演时，她没有做那种巨大的制作，她就像……她几乎就像Ziggy Stardust。她就像在乐队伴奏下唱歌。
Hey, Dave, let me ask you, what's your favorite beat of all time that always gets you? There's like, there's a song that comes on, you go like, fuck, I just love that. You know what it is? It's that reggaeton beat that's like. Is there a song that has, what is that? There's 10,000 songs to do that.
嘿，戴夫，让我问你，你最喜欢的节奏是什么，总是让你着迷？有一首歌一响，你就会想：去他的，我就是喜欢那个。你知道是什么吗？是那种雷鬼节奏，就像……有一首歌有……那是什么？有10000首歌都那样。
Like that, right. Like Justin's got one and Selena's got one. I was just thinking like, I love that. You remember that like Stone Roses, Fools, Gold? Love. Love. Yeah, it's a Manhattan beat. Well, you know, this is the thing sometimes.
就像那样，对吧。贾斯汀有一首，赛琳娜也有一首。我刚才就在想，我喜欢那个。你记得那个石玫瑰乐队的《Fools Gold》吗？喜欢。喜欢。是啊，那是曼哈顿节奏。嗯，你知道，有时候这就是问题所在。
Dave, did I get that right? I don't fucking know what any of you guys are talking about. When there's sometimes, when a beat will define a whole genre of music. And this is dangerous, I think, because then all of a sudden your band or your type of music you're playing is restricted to this one thing.
戴夫，我没说错吧？我根本不知道你们在说什么。有时候，当一个节奏定义了整个音乐流派。这很危险，我认为，因为那样的话，你的乐队或你演奏的音乐类型就会被限制在这一个东西上。
And it happens something, like trap music. When all of a sudden, when it was like, and you're going like, hit it, shove it, shove it, shove it, shove it, shove it, shove it, shove it, shove it, shove it, shove it, shove it, shove it, shove it, shove it, shove it, shove it, that was like three years ago or whatever. It's gone, right?
它会发生，比如陷阱音乐。当突然间，当它是……你就会想：打它，推它，推它……那大概是三年前的事了。它消失了，对吧？
It's gone. Exactly what you mean. Because it was the same fucking beat in every fucking song. Well, Will, I know what you're talking about. That song, that Stone Rose song, everybody emulated that beat for like seven years. Right after that, that was like 1989. And it was just like, boom.
它消失了。正是你的意思。因为每首歌里都是同一个该死的节奏。嗯，威尔，我知道你在说什么。那首石玫瑰的歌，每个人都模仿那个节奏模仿了七年。就在那之后，那是1989年。就像，砰。
All those bands out of Manchester specifically, but it was like so good. And God, I love that band. Dave, true that you broke your leg, went backstage, got a cast on it, came back out, finished the concert, then had a throne built to continue the tour. Is that correct? True. True, all of it true.
所有那些来自曼彻斯特的乐队，特别是，但它真的太好了。天哪，我爱那个乐队。戴夫，你摔断了腿，去后台打上石膏，回来继续演出，然后让人造了一把王座继续巡演，这是真的吗？真的。真的，全是真的。
All of it true. That's sort of, I fell off the stage and I just looked at my ankle and broke my leg. And then I felt no pain. So I was like, I'm gonna go fix this, I'll be right back. And I looked at the band and was like, just play a queen song, just go, go, go, go.
全是真的。那就像……我从舞台上摔下来，我看着我的脚踝，腿断了。然后我没感觉到痛。所以我当时想：我要去修好它，我马上回来。我看着乐队说：就弹一首皇后乐队的歌，走，走，走，走。
And they pulled me off to the side of the stage and the guy, it was in Sweden, he takes off my high top. And he's like, your ankle's dislocated, I must put it back in right now. And so I'm like, oh my God. So I got this huge cup of Crown Royal, I was just like bleh.
他们把我拉到舞台侧面，那个人，是在瑞典，他脱掉我的高帮鞋。他说：你的脚踝脱臼了，我现在必须把它接回去。所以我说：噢，天哪。所以我拿了一大杯皇冠威士忌，我只是……呕。
And then he puts it back in and he's holding it there. And I'm like, okay, so can I go sit down and finish the show? And he's like, why do we have to put the cast on it? And I was like, where's, okay, do you have one? He's like, no, we gotta go to the hospital. I said, how far away is that? He's like, half an hour.
然后他把它接回去了，他一直按在那儿。我说：好吧，那我能坐下完成演出吗？他说：为什么我们必须打石膏？我说：哪儿……好吧，你有石膏吗？他说：不，我们得去医院。我说：那儿有多远？他说：半小时。
I'm like, fuck that. You go get the cast and I'll go sit down. And he goes, well, if I let go of your ankle, it's just gonna fall out. And then I was like, well, then you're coming on stage, motherfucker. And this guy was like, okay. And they put this ace bandage around it.
我说：去他的。你去拿石膏，我去坐下。他说：好吧，如果我松开你的脚踝，它就会掉出来。然后我说：那你就跟我上台，混蛋。那家伙说：好吧。他们用弹性绷带把它缠起来。
And he came out with you? And held my foot. It was like, now again, I'm making decisions. And so he sat there and held it. As we played, it was a stadium. And we kept playing. Still no pain? No pain.
他跟你一起上台了？还扶着我的脚。就像，现在我又在做决定了。所以他坐在那儿扶着它。当我们演奏时，那是个体育场。我们继续演奏。还是没痛感？没痛感。
And then the throne and then you had a chair developed to continue the tour. Later gave that throne to Axel Rose. True or false? True, Axel had to use it. Oh, you wanna know what's crazy? Okay, so then Axel used it for guns and roses because he broke his foot.
然后是王座，然后你开发了一把椅子继续巡演。后来把那把王座给了阿克塞尔·罗斯。真的还是假的？真的，阿克塞尔不得不使用它。噢，你想知道什么很疯狂吗？好吧，阿克塞尔在枪花乐队用了它，因为他摔断了脚。
And then he was also singing with ACDC at the time. So then it goes on tour with ACDC for a little bit. And then I'm the guy that people call like, hey, I broke my fucking ankle, can I borrow the throne? I was like, yeah, okay. So I started sending it out to different people. But recently, like about a month ago, there was this dude in a metal band
而且他当时还在和AC/DC一起唱歌。所以它又跟着AC/DC巡演了一段时间。然后我成了人们打电话的对象，比如：嘿，我摔断了该死的脚踝，能借用一下王座吗？我说：是啊，好吧。所以我开始把它借给不同的人。但最近，大概一个月前，有个金属乐队的家伙
who stopped an active shooter at his show, at his own show. He saw this guy that was acting sketchy. And so he confronted him and the guy shot this dude in the band in the leg. And then they found his car was full of ammunition, blah, blah, blah. What? And so he and his friends started this online campaign
在演出中阻止了一名枪手，在他自己的演出中。他看到那个家伙行为可疑。所以他去质问他，那家伙朝乐队里的这个家伙腿上开了一枪。然后他们发现他的车里装满了弹药，等等。什么？所以他和他的朋友们发起了在线活动，
like, Dave, you should give him the throne. And I gave him the throne for him to play in his metal band, which was pretty reckless. So listen, if any of you guys ever need a throne, I know you've got your Spidey chair, Will, but this thing has like lasers and a smoke machine on it. That would be, that's pretty rad. That's pretty rad.
比如：戴夫，你应该把王座给他。我把王座给了他，让他可以在他的金属乐队里演奏，这相当鲁莽。所以听着，如果你们谁需要王座，我知道你有你的蜘蛛椅，威尔，但这东西上面有激光和烟雾机。那会……那挺酷的。那挺酷的。
Dave, I imagine you got some real quality house time with the wife and the girls during COVID. But now, are you back on tour? Are you back on the road? Are you thinking about it? We are, we're doing some shows here and there. We're playing, well, we've been out. We went out for the last like two and a half, three months
戴夫，我想你在疫情期间和妻子女儿们度过了一些真正高质量的居家时光。但现在，你回到巡演了吗？你回到路上了吗？你在考虑吗？我们是，我们在这里和那里做一些演出。我们正在演奏，嗯，我们一直在外面。我们出去了大概最后两三个月，
and played all through the Midwest and did Lollapalooza and reopened Madison Square Garden. Oh, that's right. That's right. We've got some more shows coming up. And then we'll like quiet down for a little bit and then do it all again. Sean, what, isn't there like a vocal exercise
在中西部到处演出，还参加了Lollapalooza，重新开放了麦迪逊广场花园。噢，没错。没错。我们还有更多演出。然后我们会安静一会儿，然后再做一遍。肖恩，什么，没有那种发声练习
or like a sentence, not like quick Brown Fox? What is the thing you say before you do a performance? I'll do it. Yeah, let's hear it, Sean. I'll do a, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, you're welcome.
或者句子，不像“敏捷的棕色狐狸”？你在表演前说的是什么？我来做。是啊，让我们听听，肖恩。我会做，妈，妈，妈，妈，妈，妈，妈，妈，妈，妈，妈，妈，妈，妈，妈，妈，妈，妈，妈，妈，妈，妈，妈，妈，妈，妈，妈，妈，妈，妈，不客气。
Wow. You can do that. Before a show. Yeah, go ahead. What do you do? Three Advil, two Coors Lights and two shots of drum roll. There it is. Is that true?
哇。你能做到。演出前。是啊，来吧。你做什么？三片止痛药，两瓶库尔斯淡啤，两杯鼓声。就是这样。那是真的吗？
26 years, 26 years, right there. Is that true? It's absolutely true. You don't smoke butts though, right? You don't smoke butts. In a pinch. I do. You do.
26年，26年，就在那儿。那是真的吗？绝对是真的。你不抽烟，对吧？你不抽烟。紧急情况下。我抽。你抽。
I do. I do all the things I'm not supposed to do. You're a rock star, God damn it. It's not even that. I'm just a fuck up and I'm too lazy to do the thing Sean did before a show. You're not a fuck up. And terrified someone will hear me doing that.
我抽。我做所有我不该做的事。你是个摇滚明星，该死的。甚至不是那样。我只是个混蛋，我太懒了，做不到肖恩演出前做的那种事。你不是个混蛋。而且害怕有人听到我那样做。
But here is the deal and I don't want to embarrass you. You have been an incredibly relevant figure in rock and roll for a long, long time. You've made all these records. You have a family. You are getting up early. You're going to bed early. You're still doing all the rock star things,
但这就是交易，我不想让你尴尬。你在摇滚乐中一直是一个极其重要的人物，很长很长时间了。你制作了所有这些唱片。你有家庭。你起得很早。你睡得很早。你依然在做所有摇滚明星的事，
but you're managing to juggle the other side as well. My hat is off to you, my friend. You definitely won. Jason is really impressed with how early you get up. Because he's just like, that's the mark of somebody who's serious. Well, you can't fake that. Shut the fuck up. We're not going to fit in your fucking box, Bateman.
但你设法兼顾了另一面。我向你致敬，我的朋友。你绝对赢了。杰森对你起得这么早印象深刻。因为他觉得，那是认真的人的标志。嗯，你不能伪装那个。闭上你的臭嘴。我们不会塞进你那个该死的盒子里，贝特曼。
OK? Of what you've drawn up, what you think should be. Because you don't even do it yourself. Shut the fuck up. I've had enough of it. Dave, Dave, you and I are rock stars, man. And we're doing it differently than everybody else. Said from a Spidey chair.
OK？你画出来的，你认为应该是什么样的。因为你自己甚至都做不到。闭上你的臭嘴。我受够了。戴夫，戴夫，你和我都是摇滚明星，伙计。我们做的方式和别人不一样。坐在蜘蛛椅上说的。
It doesn't matter. You're a fucking rad dude. And come on over to the house. We're going to lift. And I'm going to get you into sports. Sean's going to tap dance with you. And he's going to get you into promises and promise. And Bateman, you can go and eff yourself.
没关系。你是个该死的酷家伙。来我家吧。我们要去举重。我要让你爱上体育。肖恩要和你跳踢踏舞。他要让你爱上《承诺，承诺》。贝特曼，你可以去死吧。
And that's our show. And with that, sweet, sweet Dave Grohl, thank you for joining us. I'll see you at Trader Vic. So cool to meet you, Dave. You're a treasure. What a pleasure to meet you. Thanks, fellas.
这就是我们的节目。带着那个，甜甜的戴夫·格罗尔，谢谢你加入我们。我在Trader Vic见你。见到你真酷，戴夫。你是个宝藏。见到你真是荣幸。谢谢，伙计们。
We'll see you around. OK. See you, man. Bye. Bye, buddy. That Dave Grohl. Jason, what a great guest. Look, I fanned out about the Nirvana thing
我们回头见。OK。再见，伙计。再见。再见，哥们。那个戴夫·格罗尔。杰森，真是个伟大的嘉宾。看，我因为涅槃乐队的事成了粉丝，
because I grew up listening to him. So I tried very hard not to ask any Nirvana questions. He doesn't want to talk about Nirvana. Why not, though? Well, because that's all he's ever talked about. Everybody always wants to ask about Nirvana. It's like this guy, I don't know. Because it's one of the most iconic bands of all time.
因为我是听着他的歌长大的。所以我非常努力地不去问任何关于涅槃的问题。他不想谈论涅槃。为什么不呢？嗯，因为那是他谈论过的一切。每个人总是想问关于涅槃的事。就像这家伙，我不知道。因为那是史上最具标志性的乐队之一。
That's not fair. He's done 14,000 albums with the Foo Fighters. That's like somebody saying, you can't ask you. And that was our question or an arrest development question. Well, but did we hammer Paul McCartney about the Beatles? No? We should have. We should.
这不公平。他和喷火战机乐队一起制作了14000张专辑。这就像有人说，你不能问你。那是我们的问题，或者是《发展受阻》的问题。好吧，但我们有没有就披头士乐队的问题去纠缠保罗·麦卡特尼？没有吧？我们本该这么做的。我们应该。
We should have. We did. We talked a little bit about him being from Liverpool. And we bring up Teen Wolf 2 all the time with you. We can't not talk about that. I do enjoy talking about that. Because you, as you point out, it's Teen Wolf also. Yeah, it teed up a little.
我们本该这么做的。我们确实问了。我们聊了一点关于他来自利物浦的事。而且我们总是和你提起《狼人2》。我们不能不谈那个。我确实很喜欢谈论那个。因为正如你指出的，那也是《狼人》。是的，它稍微铺垫了一下。
Yeah, it was not a sequel. It was not a sequel. He's great. Super guy, super funny. And he's got a brand new book out. I should have asked him. It's called The Storyteller. Is it called The Storyteller?
是的，那不是续集。那不是续集。他很棒。超级棒的人，超级风趣。他刚出了一本新书。我本该问他的。书名叫《说书人》。是叫《说书人》吗？
It's called The Storyteller. It's your favorite term, Will. It's tough. I'm going to have to. It's tough. But I do love Dave. And by the way, if you're actually writing a book and you called The Storyteller, that's OK.
书名叫《说书人》。这是你最喜欢的词，威尔。这很难。我不得不……这很难。但我确实很喜欢戴夫。顺便说一句，如果你真的在写一本书，而且你把它叫作《说书人》，那没关系。
So do you guys get the same sort of vibe from him that you do from me? Because we share the same exact day. I mean, do you believe in all that? Like astrology and people born on the same day are kind of the same people? Do you think Rockstar, when you look at me, when you talk to me?
那么你们从他身上感受到的氛围和我一样吗？因为我们是同一天生日。我是说，你们相信这一切吗？比如占星术，或者同一天出生的人本质上是同一种人？当你看着我，当你和我说话时，你会觉得我是摇滚明星吗？
First of all, I don't think that's true. I think that if you were born at the same minute, maybe, at the same place. I didn't really go that micro with it. Well, why wouldn't you? I like when he said, the parts of the band, he associated us with a clock, where like the big gear moves a little slower,
首先，我不认为那是真的。我认为如果你是在同一分钟，甚至同一个地方出生的，也许吧。我没有真的去研究得那么细。好吧，你为什么不呢？我喜欢他说乐队成员的部分，他把我们比作时钟，大齿轮转得慢一点，
the little one moves faster, and they all come together. Will, how would you describe us three as the internal parts of a clock? First of all, I didn't know that we were going around doing like, I like when he said, oh, OK. And I like when he said, oh, no, I just remembered it. I remembered it. I like that analogy, too.
小齿轮转得快一点，它们汇聚在一起。威尔，你会怎么描述我们三个作为时钟的内部零件？首先，我不知道我们是在到处做这种……我喜欢他说，哦，好的。我喜欢他说，哦，不，我刚想起来了。我想起来了。我也喜欢那个比喻。
I thought that was really, really cool. Would you call me the big cock? No, there's an L, clock. Clock? Big cock, big cock. A cock, yeah. But you were very, you were real slurry on that. I was trying to slur the G just to get a joke.
我觉得那真的非常非常酷。你会叫我大“公鸡”（cock）吗？不，有个L，是“时钟”（clock）。时钟？大公鸡，大公鸡。公鸡，是的。但你刚才说得含糊不清。我只是想把那个G音含糊过去，好开个玩笑。
I remember the big cock. I like the analogy of, I like the analogy if we were all board games. I would say, I would say Jason's chess. Will, you're checkers, and I'm probably shooting like this. Sorry. You think so? Oh, I thought you were going to say sorry.
我记得那个大公鸡。我喜欢那个比喻，如果我们要把自己比作棋盘游戏的话。我会说，我会说杰森是国际象棋。威尔，你是跳棋，而我大概是像这样乱射。抱歉。你这么认为吗？哦，我以为你要说抱歉。
Or I'm sorry, yeah. Well, why am I checkers? Yeah, because I'm chess. Yeah, because you're right in that. He's just calling it like he sees it, Will, you know? What are you talking about? Are you talk to Bateman? Because you travel a lot.
或者我很抱歉，是的。好吧，为什么我是跳棋？是的，因为我是国际象棋。是的，因为你说得对。他只是实话实说，威尔，你知道的。你在说什么？你在和贝特曼说话吗？因为你经常旅行。
You can travel with checkers a little bit easier. Oh, yeah, you guys have traveled. I want to talk about that, by the way. We've never taken a trip. We're going to. Just the two of us. No, just the two of us. You, me, Sean, or you, me, Will.
带着跳棋旅行稍微容易一点。哦，是的，你们旅行过。顺便说一句，我想谈谈这个。我们从来没一起去旅行过。我们要去了。就我们俩。不，就我们俩。你、我、肖恩，或者你、我、威尔。
We're going to do a threesome coming up in February. Get your tickies. Get your tickies. And I mentioned the merch because I did. I have, we each got one of those smart-less hoodies. When we first were coming up with it and the people who made them sent it to us. You're not going to wear that, are you?
我们二月份要搞个三人行。去买票吧。去买票吧。我提到了周边商品，因为我确实买了。我们每个人都有一件那种Smart-less连帽衫。当我们刚开始构思它的时候，制作它们的人寄给了我们。你不会穿那个吧，是吗？
You can't wear your own stuff. Well, this is what I'm getting to. So they sent it to the three of us to say like, hey, what do you think, right? And we all got one. And before they went on sale on the website. And so I still have mine. And it's hanging in the closet the other day.
你不能穿你自己的周边。好吧，这就是我要说的。所以他们寄给了我们三个人，说，嘿，你们觉得怎么样，对吧？我们每个人都拿到了一件。在它们在网站上开售之前。所以我还有我的那件。前几天它挂在衣柜里。
I had it on. And sometimes they're wearing it around the house because it's actually very nice. And this is not me trying to say, they're really comfy. You should get it. Super comfy. They just put it on. And I said to the kids, I was like,
我穿上了它。有时候我在家里穿着它，因为它真的很舒服。这不是我在试图推销，它们真的很舒服。你应该买一件。超级舒服。他们刚穿上它。我对孩子们说，我说，
I can't wear this outside of the house ever. Cause I'm like, hey, look, Hey, there's the guy wearing his own face. Yeah. And did Archie and Abel say, you can't wear it here either. Get it off. No, they didn't.
我永远不能在屋外穿这个。因为我会觉得，嘿，看，嘿，那个穿着印有自己脸的衣服的家伙在那儿。是的。阿奇和阿贝尔有没有说，你也不能在这儿穿。脱掉它。不，他们没说。
But let me ask you something, Jason. You must have Ozark swag. Do you wear it and do you wear it outside of the house? I give a lot of it away. I've got two hats that I still, I keep in my closet for some weird reason. Like I'm going to wear them one day, which I can't. I can't go out with it.
但让我问你一件事，杰森。你一定有《黑钱胜地》的周边吧。你穿它吗？你在屋外穿它吗？我送出去了很多。我有两顶帽子，出于某种奇怪的原因，我还是留在了衣柜里。好像我哪天会戴它们一样，但我不能。我不能戴着它出门。
You're one of the, Jason, are you one of those like you wear like a panavision hat? Like, Hey, just ask me if I'm a director. Yeah. A stunts unlimited hat. Just thank them for something to ask. Go ahead. Just please ask me.
你是那种人吗，杰森，你会戴着像Panavision（摄影机品牌）的帽子吗？就像，嘿，快问我是不是导演。是的。一顶“特技无限”的帽子。只是为了让别人问点什么。来吧。请问我吧。
What kind of mat do you use? Yeah. Something like that. Well, that's how I felt about the set, bringing, we've talked about the segues before. Remember, Jason remembers Sean, when I was on Arrested Development, which was a show Jason and I were on,
你用什么垫子？是的。类似那样的。好吧，这就是我对赛格威（Segway）的感觉，我们之前谈过转场。记得吗，杰森记得肖恩，当我在《发展受阻》的时候，那是杰森和我一起演的剧，
which again, you got to see. The comedy. Yeah. You should see it. Cause you like comedy. And I use, my character used to ride one of those segues, those, you know, personal people, single, whatever, people movers.
那部剧你一定要看。喜剧。是的。你应该看看。因为你喜欢喜剧。我用……我的角色过去常骑那种赛格威，那种，你知道，个人代步工具，单人，什么的，代步车。
The segues. Something like that. Something like that. And I drove that thing around. It's really fun to, they were fun to ride. I could never ride it from that moment on. Cause it'd be like, Hey, Hey guy, are you riding your proper around?
赛格威。类似那样的。类似那样的。我骑着那东西到处转。骑起来真的很有趣。从那以后我就再也没法骑它了。因为那会像是，嘿，嘿伙计，你在骑你的道具吗？
It's not funny. You know, you're going to think I'm a nerd, but like I actually did like sweater vest before my character, Jack McFarland. Now I can never wear a sweater vest. Yeah. You can never wear it. Nope. Yeah. And now Jason can never wear khakis
这不好笑。你知道，你会觉得我是个书呆子，但我其实在我的角色杰克·麦克法兰之前就喜欢毛衣背心。现在我再也不能穿毛衣背心了。是的。你永远不能穿了。不。是的。现在杰森再也不能穿卡其裤
with a sleaze rolled up on a shirt. Oh wait. He does it all the time. That's our show. Bye. Bye. Really? Oh yeah. Sorry.
配上卷起袖子的衬衫了。哦等等。他一直都这么穿。那是我们的节目。再见。再见。真的吗？哦是的。抱歉。
Wait, was that a real buy or no? No, I don't think it can. By the way, I took a little heat the other day we were talking, I was talking to some friends and they're like, they're like, Hey, are you serious with the buys at the end of every episode? What do you mean?
等等，那是真的再见还是假的？不，我不觉得那是真的。顺便说一句，前几天我受到了一点压力，我们在聊天，我和一些朋友在谈话，他们说，他们说，嘿，你们在每集结尾说“再见”是认真的吗？你什么意思？
Are you serious? Like they're, they're like saying, because remember the only reason we're doing it is because it's the most obnoxious, annoying thing. It's a joke. But I think we're past the joke now. And now it's just awful. What do you think?
你是认真的吗？就像他们，他们说，因为记住我们这么做的唯一原因是因为这是最令人讨厌、最烦人的事情。这只是个玩笑。但我认为我们现在已经过了那个玩笑的阶段了。现在这只是糟糕透顶。你怎么看？
Wait, wait, who? By the way, it goes, it depends on who said it. Who asked that? Somebody who's not prone to cynicism at all. It's actually somebody I was working with like a sound crew, like engineers at a post production session. When you were doing, you were doing a session for Hyundai?
等等，等等，谁？顺便说一句，这取决于谁说的。谁问的？一个一点也不愤世嫉俗的人。其实是我一起工作的人，比如音响组，后期制作会议上的工程师。当你在做的时候，你在为现代汽车做录音？
No, a different, you know, which by the way, it's a fantastic car. Oh God. If you like safety and if you like economy and handsome lines. Anyway, so should we, should we change that at all? No. Well, we've run out of all the pun.
不，另一个，你知道，顺便说一句，那是一辆很棒的车。哦天哪。如果你喜欢安全，如果你喜欢经济实惠和帅气的线条。总之，那么我们应该，我们应该改变一下吗？不。好吧，我们已经用完了所有的双关语。
How about like a see ya? Why don't we move on to see ya? Yeah. Hang on, hang on, hang on. I'm not taking fucking notes from people. I don't give a shit what they think. I hate when people go, you know, so I'll tell you this, this is my last point.
比如“回头见”怎么样？我们为什么不换成“回头见”呢？是的。等等，等等，等等。我才不听那些人的废话。我不在乎他们怎么想。我讨厌人们说，你知道，所以我告诉你这个，这是我最后一点。
And then you guys, I was in Toronto and I was with our friend Shani this week from Toronto. Friend and Shani had Tracy. At the, friend and Shani had from the Leafs game for Tracy. Who's the president of the Leafs. Love him. And he calls. Nice home opener win.
然后你们，我在多伦多，这周我和我们的朋友沙尼在一起，他来自多伦多。朋友沙尼有特雷西。在，朋友沙尼有枫叶队的比赛门票给特雷西。他是枫叶队的主席。爱死他了。他打来电话。主场揭幕战赢得很漂亮。
Did you go to the home opener? I was at the home opener with my dad. Sure you were. Yep, nice big win. And I was with my dad and a couple buddies and was there with Shani. We had a nice little dinner before and then we were at the thing.
你去看揭幕战了吗？我和我爸在揭幕战现场。你当然去了。是的，漂亮的开门红。我和我爸还有几个哥们在一起，沙尼也在那儿。我们在那儿之前吃了一顿不错的晚餐，然后我们就去了那儿。
Pushing through. Pushing through. And so anyway, so we were watching the thing and I said, you know that Shani often after one of our podcasts, you know, episodes comes out, he'll call me or text me and he'll be like, that was pretty good. You know what, I thought when Bateman said that was good
坚持住。坚持住。总之，我们当时在看比赛，我说，你知道沙尼经常在我们的一期播客播出后，他会打电话或发短信给我，他会说，那期挺不错的。你知道吗，当贝特曼说那话的时候，我觉得挺好的
and I liked when Shani, he'll do it like every week. We'll talk on the phone, he'll have notes. So I realized we're watching the end of the Leafs game and his brother was there and a couple other people I go, you know, I turned to Shani and I go, you know what, man? I go, you call me after the podcast and you give me notes on the show.
我喜欢沙尼说的，他每周都会这么做。我们会在电话里聊，他会有意见。所以我意识到我们正在看枫叶队比赛的结尾，他哥哥也在那儿，还有其他几个人，我说，你知道，我转向沙尼说，你知道吗，伙计？我说，你在播客结束后打电话给我，给我提节目的意见。
So guess what, after tonight's game, I got some notes, dude. The third line needs some work. I got some notes. And did you give them? Yeah, I sure did. Did he take them? Has he implemented them yet? Well, it's all about puck possession, right?
所以你猜怎么着，今晚比赛结束后，我也有点意见，伙计。第三组需要改进。我有点意见。你提了吗？是的，我当然提了。他采纳了吗？他实施了吗？好吧，这全在于控球，对吧？
And I think Sean, you'd agree. Yeah, I know, puck possession for sure. You could just jockey for a better puck position. And forecheck. Possession. Possession, that's what I said. Oh, you did, sorry, I've just heard. Hey, Sean, serious question.
我想肖恩你会同意的。是的，我知道，控球当然很重要。你可以为了更好的控球位置而争抢。还有前场逼抢。控球。控球，我就是这么说的。哦，你说了，抱歉，我只是听到了。嘿，肖恩，严肃的问题。
If you were to spell forecheck, would you spell it F-O-U-R or F-O-R-E? First of all, I don't know what that is. That's why I'm asking you. On a gentleman from Prague and he's not cut, he's got a forecheck. Is that what you were saying? Now I got to say bye.
如果你要拼写“前场逼抢”（forecheck），你会拼成F-O-U-R还是F-O-R-E？首先，我不知道那是什么。这就是我问你的原因。关于一个来自布拉格的绅士，他没割礼，他有个前场逼抢。这就是你要说的吗？现在我得说再见了。
Bye. Bye. Bye. Smart. What. Smart. What. Smart.
再见。再见。再见。聪明。什么。聪明。什么。聪明。
What. Smart. What. Smart. What. What. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjalf, and Bennett
什么。聪明。什么。聪明。什么。什么。SmartLess是由迈克尔·格兰特·特里、罗布·阿姆贾尔夫和贝内特制作的100%有机且手工制作的节目。
Barbeco. SmartLess. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Barbeco。SmartLess。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。